UNLESS I THINK PEOPLE ARE READY
TO GO OKAY- AND LET ME JUST THE
THANK THE STAFF- I KNOW WE HAD
A COMMITTEE THAT ENDED AND
SOME. POTENTIAL CONCERN ABOUT
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES BETWEEN
THE TWO HEARING SO IT COST US
TO START A LITTLE BIT LATE
TODAY SO. FORGIVE ME BUT I WANT
TO EXTEND MY APPRECIATION TO
STAFF FOR THE INCREDIBLE JOB
THEY CONTINUE TO DO AS WE HOLD
THESE HEARINGS IN COMMITTEES
ARE. IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAN WE
ARE USED TO- ABSENT THE
PANDEMIC. SO LET ME GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON RULES TO ORDER FOR AUGUST
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M GOING TO
AGAIN BE MAKING SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESS SEES WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE. OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH OUR PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO MIGHT BE TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME. I WANT T COVER
SOME TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THIS
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
THE DAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COBIT NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. SENATOR
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. SO
IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
LOCAL ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
WE HAVE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS. TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH. AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. SENATORS
AND OUR EMPLOYEES TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WE WILL ALSO.
BE USING TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INTO WHO WISH TO
TODAY AND SO FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTISAN
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE ONE NINE NINE
FOUR THREE AND AGAIN THAT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT ONE
ONE NINE NINE FOUR THREE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COM A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LAN AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND IF YOU
DON'T DO IT IN THAT MANNER WE
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND-
AND THERE MAY BE- BACKGROUND
NOISE AND STATIC SO WE THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
TO CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEWONLINE
TOOL SO PLEASE BE PATIENT. SO
THAT EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR
STENOGRAPHER I WILL ASK ALL
SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES A LIGHT. TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. SO BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA I NEED
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND AS A
REMINDER TO MEMBERS YOU WILL
NEED TO TURN YOUR MICROPHONES
ON FOR ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME
THAT YOU SPEAK AT AND WHEN YOU
VOTE. SO MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR
MONNING YEAR LEARNING HERE ROTH
YOUR- ROTH HERE WILK PRESIDENT
WILL PRESENT ATKINS. HERE
ATKINS HERE Q. MADAM SECRETARY
SO WE WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AT OUR FIRST
APPOINTEES MISTER DAVID SHAW
BAYESIAN AND I HOPE I GOT YOUR
NAME RIGHT WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION LET ME WELCOME YOU
AND I ASK IF THERE IS ANYONE
WITH YOU THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE OR KNOWLEDGE- WE
WELCOME THOSE INTRODUCTIONS AND
THEN GO AHEAD WITH YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS. AND AFTER YOUR
STATEMENT I WILL MOVE TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS OF THE
SENATORS- DIRECTLY AND SO WITH
THAT I THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
THE MEDICAL EXAMINING AND
MEMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY A FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF MY
CONFIRMATION. MY NAME IS DAVID
SHOULD REYES AND I AM THE
NOMINEE FOR THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION. I
DO WANT TO START BY RECOGNIZING
MY WIFE MICHELLE AND MY
DAUGHTER EVELYN. THEIR LOVE AND
ENCOURAGEMENT AND SUPPORT HAS
MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR ME TO TAKE
ON THIS ROLE. I AM HONORED BY
THE CONFIDENCE OF THE GOVERNOR
AND SECRETARY ROADSIDE IN MY
ABILITY TO LEAD THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION. AND I'VE BEEN
INCREDIBLY IMPRESSED AND
INSPIRED BY THE DEPTH OF
KNOWLEDGE AND COMMITMENT THE
STAFF AT THE DEPARTMENT. THEY
HELPED ME GET UP TO SPEED AND
HELPED ME SHAPE. MY VISION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT GOING FORWARD. I
SPENT CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE
BUILDING PARTNERSHIPS TO
IMPROVE OUR BUILT AND NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. AND OUR QUALITY OF
LIFE. WORK AT THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL SCALE ON PLANNING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION AND OVER THE
LAST TWELVE YEARS FOCUSED ON
STRATEGIES TO CONSERVE AND
MANAGE OUR NOT RESOURCE. SUCH
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES
THESE RESOURCES PROVIDE. BUT
ALSO ENHANCE THE ECONOMIC VALUE
FROM THE INDUSTRIES AND THE
JOBS THAT RELY ON AND UTILIZE
THESE RESOURCES. AND FURTHER
MORE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE BENEFITS ARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THOSE LIVING IN
BOTH RURAL AND URBAN PARTS OF
OUR STATE. AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
ENVIRONMENT HAS INHERENT RISKS
AND HAZARDS THAT WE MUST BE
PREPARED FOR. OUR CHALLENGE AND
OUR OPPORTUNITY IS TO ENSURE
RESPONSIBLE STEWARDSHIP OF OUR
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT OUR STATE
TODAY BUT ALSO FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION'S MISSION. AND
IT'S ALSO THE COMBINATION OF MY
PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND PASSION. MY
VISION FOR THE DEPARTMENT DOES
NOT REQUIRED NEW PROGRAMS OR A
MAJOR REORGANIZATION. RATHER A
NEW WAY OF LOOKING AT OUR
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS IN TERMS
OF THE NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS DIRECTIVES OF THE
GOVERNOR. SECRETARY PRO CLINTON
LEGISLATURE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION HAS A UNIQUE
COLLECTION OF DIVISIONS THAT
ENCOMPASS BOTH THE SURFACE AND
SUBSURFACE ASPECTS OF NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS. I AM
BUILDING OF ONE OF THEIR
PROGRAMS AND THE RICH SCIENCE
AND TECHNICAL CAPACITY WE HAVE
ALL OF OUR DIVISIONS. TO
D
WITHIN AND OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. TO HELP US ADVANCE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION AND
MANAGEMENT FOR BOTH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS FOR TODAY AND INTO THE
FUTURE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF MY NOMINATION
AS DIRECTOR OF. THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE FUTURE.
CHARACTER THANK YOU SO MUCH LET
ME GO AHEAD AND GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES AND US SENATOR ROTH
IF YOU'RE READY I WILL START
WITH YOU. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM UM TO REMOVE DIRECTOR
CONGRATULATIONS MY- STAFF TELLS
ME THAT THIS IS YOUR BIRTHDAY
AND IF THAT'S TRUE HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT I'M PLEASED TO TELL YOU
THAT I HAVE NO QUESTIONS AND I
WOULD BE DELIGHTED TO SUPPORT
FEWER WILL BE DELIGHTED TO
SUPPORT YOUR CONFIRMATION AND
IF PERMITTED MAKE THE
NOMINATION TO DO SO. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AGAIN
RESOLUTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF THAT'S
EXCELLENT STAFF WORK ON MY DAD.
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM. SO MY STAFF
TELLS ME ARMENIAN. BUT AT
BOTTOM SO. I JUST SO YEAH I GET
AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS I JUST
I'VE GOT JUST ONE QUESTION FOR
YOU- AS YOU KNOW ABOUT 70% OF
THE OF THE OIL DEMAND FOR
CALIFORNIANS COMES FROM
ELSEWHERE IN MOST AFTER THE
MIDDLE EAST AND COURSE IF YOU
YOU SEE PICTURES ON THE COAST
HAS BEEN- JUST. THIS YEAR JUST
A MASSIVE YEAR FOR THESE OIL
SUPERTANKERS OFF THE COAST IS
THERE ANY IS THERE ANY ROLE FOR
YOUR DEPARTMENT TO PLAY. INTO
ENSURING THAT WE'RE NOT THAT WE
DON'T BECOME MORE DEPENDENT ON
FOREIGN OIL THAT DOESN'T REALLY
FALL INTO THE DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATIONS ROLE- BE THERE
ARE STUDIES UNDER WAY
CURRENTLY- AT CALIFORNIA. A
LOOKING AT- THE FUTURE AND
TOWARD- OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND
CHANGES. IN THE MARKETPLACE.
REALLY ARE OUR ROLE IN THE OIL
AND GAS INDUSTRY IS TO
IMPLEMENT THE REGULATIONS
PROMULGATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND TO DO THAT TO THAT THE
LETTER LAWS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
INCISION IN SINCE YOU'VE BEEN
THERE- WHAT HAVE YOU DONE ON
TERMS INCREASING COLLABORATION
BETWEEN BECAUSE YOU GOT
BASICALLY FOUR PILLARS OF
RESPONSIBILITY HAVE YOU HAVE
YOU. TAKE ANY ACTIONS TO
INCREASE AND IMPROVE THAT
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION
OR WAS IT ALREADY GOOD WHEN YOU
GOT THERE. YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO
WE DO HAVE FOUR DIVISIONS AND-
I THINK OFTEN TIMES PEOPLE LOOK
AT THOSE DIVISIONS AND THINK
THAT THEY REALLY ARE JUST
SEPARATE AND THEY DO SEPARATE
THINGS BUT BUT MY VIEW OF OUR
FOUR DIVISIONS ACT WE- WE ARE
TACKLING. MANY UP THE ACTUAL
WORKING LANDS CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FROM FROM MAYBE
FROM DIFFERENT ANGLES BUT WE'RE
ALL AIMING TOWARDS THE SAME
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES AND SO IN
IN LOOKING AT THAT AND KIND OF
TAKING A STEP BACK AND- AT. THE
THAT WE HAVE WITHIN EACH OF OUR
DIVISIONS AND THE PROGRAM'S
HIGH END SCENE WHERE THERE'S
REALLY SYNERGY BETWEEN THOSE
AND- I DON'T THINK YOU'D BE
SURPRISED TO SEE THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY A LOT OF SYNERGY
BETWEEN THOSE THOSE DIVISIONS.
ARE BECAUSE WE ARE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS NATURAL
WORKING LAND TO CALIFORNIA IN
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF THOSE WHO
PUT THEM TOGETHER WERE MORE
COMPETITION SOME. HIGH LEVEL
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN SENT BY
THE GOVERNOR BY THE SECRETARY-
AND WE SEE OURSELVES. IN A
CENTRAL ROLE IN MANY OF THOSE
ASPECTS GREAT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ANSWERS AGAIN HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. NOW LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION
ONCE- SENATOR OFF. MAKES IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIRMAN. CENTER MINING I DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DUE TO TOP OF
THOSE TWO OPENING COMMENTS SAID
THAT YOUR STAFF YEAH WELL
THEY'RE EXCELLENT BY THE WAY.
AND MY BIRTHDAY GREETINGS TO
YOU DIRECTOR AND- I DID
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY WE
HAD TO SPEAK. THE OTHER DAY IN.
ONE OF THE AREAS UNDER YOUR-
JURISDICTION OF COURSE IS CAL
JAM FORMERLY DUGGAR. THERE WERE
A LARGE NUMBER OF PERMITS
ISSUED APPARENTLY- PRIOR TO
THAT. TRANSITION OF LEADERSHIP.
LINKING THAT OVERSIGHT TO
COUNTY M. ANA TO OIL EXTRACTION
FRACKING HOW HIS COVERT
NINETEEN IMPACTED. THE
DIVISION'S ABILITY TO MONITOR
AND PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER TO IT YOU KNOW
IT REALLY HAS NOT WE WERE ABLE
TO TRANSITION FAIRLY SEAMLESSLY
FROM OFFICE TO DO HOMEWORK TO
OUR VIRTUAL WORK ENVIRONMENTS-
AND SO WE DIDN'T REALLY MISS A
BEAT AND- ALL OF THE WORK THAT
WE DO TO OVERSEE- THAT THE
REGULATIONS APPLY TO THE
INDUSTRY- AND SO I WOULD SAY
JUST IN SHORT ACT YOU KNOW KOBE
IT IS ACTUALLY- HASN'T REALLY
INTERRUPTED OUR OUR OUR
OPERATIONS AND OUR CONNECTIONS
AND IN FACT WE FOUND WAYS TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT IN
THIS VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT. AND
TO START PILOTING NEW IDEAS AND
METHODS FOR HOW TO DO OUR WORK.
GREAT WELL THANK YOU. AND THEN
THE OTHER AREA WE DISCUSSED
THAT I'M PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN IS THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGIC SURVEY THE- SIZE MAKE-
MONITORING AND COLLABORATION
AMONG. DIFFERENT PARTNERS- AND
THEN THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE SHAKE ALERT- AS PEOPLE SAY
YOU CAN'T PREDICT AN EARTHQUAKE
BUT THERE CAN THERE'S
TECHNOLOGY FOR EARLY. AWARENESS
OF GROUND MOVEMENT COULD YOU
JUST GIVE US A QUICK UPDATE THE
STATUS OF SHAKE ALERT AND HOW
MUCH OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS. PROTECTED BY THAT IF AT ALL
AT THIS STAGE. YES WILL WE
CONTINUE TO DEPLOY OUR SENSORS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- CONCENTRATING ON
AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO SEE MORE
SEISMIC ACTIVITY ON A REGULAR
BASIS- AND WORKING OUT FROM
THERE YOU KNOW OUR OUR WORK IS
RATHER ENDLESS I WOULD HAVE TO
SAY BECAUSE CAL. IS RATHER
ACTIVE SO WE ARE WE ARE DOING
THE BEST THAT WE CAN DO TO GET-
SENSORS OUT IN THE FIELD- GET
THOSE OUT OF SYNC DEVON LINKED
INTO A CENTRAL SYSTEM- AND GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT TO THE
PUBLIC AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE-
YOU KNOW THE DATA YOU'RE RIGHT
WE CANNOT PREDICT EARTHQUAKES
BUT WE'RE GETTING BETTER AND
THE INFORMATION IS MOVING
FASTER OUT TO THE PUBLIC SO
THAT THEY ARE ALERTED WHEN
SOMETHING STARTS TO HAPPEN- AND
TRYING TO GIVE THEM THAT THE
VALUABLE SECONDS THAT THEY NEED
TO. ADAM DOWN AND COVER OR
THERE'S- AND SO I WE CONTINUE
TO CHIP AWAY AT THAT- AND AS I
MENTIONED WE ARE WE ARE DOING%
OUR BEST WITH WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE. TO GET
MORE MORE SENSORS OUT INTO THE
FIELD AND WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS. THANK U. S. U. S. AND
IT. AGENCIES. THAT THAT. IN THE
SPACE. I TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHERE WORKING TO. ACCORDING I
WILL PULLING A RESEARCH
TOGETHER AND AGAIN IN. THE
SPEED AT WHICH WE GET FOR. OUT
TO THE PUBLIC. THANK THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT NINE NOW. AS
CALIFORNIANS WE KNOW IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF WHETHER THEY'LL BE.
FUTURE SEISMIC EVENTS THE
QUESTION IS WHEN IN TERMS OF
ONES THAT MAY BE. DISASTROUS IN
PROPORTION AND I THINK ONE OF
THE BENEFITS OF THE EARLY
SENSOR IS TO POTENTIALLY
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM BEING
CAUGHT IN ELEVATORS OR TO STOP
ON. TRANSIT SYSTEMS ALL
DESIGNED TO PROTECT PEOPLE WITH
EVEN A FEW SECONDS OF WARNING
IN AN I KNOW FUNDING IS AN
ISSUE BUT I HOPE YOU. THREE
YEAR DEPARTMENT WILL CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE PROGRESS OF THAT WORK AND-
HOW RESOURCES FUTURE RESOURCES
MIGHT HELP FURTHER DEVELOP THAT
AND- I'LL JUST CLOSE BY
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR CAREER
PUBLIC SERVICE IN.
CONGRATULATING YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND I THANK YOU FOR
SPENDING YOUR PART OF YOUR
BIRTHDAY WITH US AND I REALLY
LIKE THE BACKDROP I DON'T KNOW
IF I'VE SEEN THAT LOGO BUT IT'S
A GREAT LOGO FOR DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH A SENATOR AND THANK
YOU FOR THOSE. COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS I'M GONNA GO NOW TO-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND- I
THINK AS A REMINDER WE GAVE THE
NUMBER OF FOR THOSE WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING- DURING THE
TELECONFERENCE PART. THAT PHONE
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 ACCESS
CODE EIGHT ONE ONE NINE NINE
FOUR THREE. I GIVE THAT NOW SO
PEOPLE CAN BE PREPARED BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE- IN SUPPORT. AND SEEING I
NO ONE HERE LET ME AT LEAST
LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHERE
WE HAVE A SECOND ROOM. OF ANY
ONE WANTS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
I SEE R. NO ONE THERE SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS-
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD- LET US
KNOW IF YOU'RE THERE AND READY
TO GO. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE YOU MAY NEED TO
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
LINE TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS DON TAYLOR CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN THANK YOU GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF. THE CONFIRMATION OF
DAVID CHIU BAYESIAN AS DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION. MY NAME IS DON
SAYLOR I'M YELLOW COUNTY
SUPERVISOR REPRESENTING
DISTRICT TWO. WHICH INCLUDES
DAVIS SAID WINTERS THE CAMPUS
OF UC DAVIS ON THE FARMLAND. IN
SOUTHWESTERN OKAY. I ALSO HAVE
SERVED SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS AND WAS CHAIR OF
THAT BOARD IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. FIVE MATT MATT DAVID
SHOULD INTO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
WE'RE WITH HIM. OVER TWELVE
WELL ABOUT TWO YEAR. FUNDAY ARE
HIS F. ON THE WINNING WORLD CAN
FOR. BUT THE I HAVE OBSERVED
DAVID CIRCOLO LEADERSHIP. I
WATCHED HIM AS HE BROUGHT
DISPARATE PART TOGETHER AND
ALLOW TO THE GREATER GOOD FOR
OUR RE. AND SAYS NEEDS OPPOSE
OUR AND COMMUNITIES. DAVID HAS
AMPLE THIS WORKING SECOND READ.
TO NATIONAL RATE. AND RECEIVE.
A BIG JAYADRATHA KENNEDY NUMBER
ENTERED ARE GO AWARD. AND HAS
ROCKY FOR HIS DENTAL HIS PER.
THAT DEPICTS. IN CON PLANNING
IN THE- THAT ARE PREDISPOSED
TO. LEADERSHIP IS A NATIONAL
RECOGNIZED THOUGHT IN LAND. AND
THERE'S NO ONE WHO WAS THERE
ARE QUITE TO SERVE AS DIRECTOR
OF THE TO OF COUNTRY. OF
CONSERVE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BY WELL I ME TO SPEAK SUPPORT
OF DAVID COMPROMISE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE LINE TWO
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROBERT DO CAN HEAR ON THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION AND
INDUSTRIAL MATERIALS
ASSOCIATION I ALSO HAVE A NIGHT
JOB AS A DIRECTOR OF THE
PLASTER COUNTY WATER AGENCY
AND- SIT ON THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY IN SACRAMENTO AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY. AND I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO SUPPORT DAVID AND
KEEPING IT SHORT THE ONLY THING
I'LL ADD BECAUSE I THINK
SUPERVISORS SAY SHALER ARE IN A
GREAT JOB AS- WE'VE GOTTEN TO
SEE THE TYPE OF INNOVATION. ON
THE DAVID CAN BRING TO THE
TABLE AND THAT INNOVATION IS
GOING TO BE A TERRIFIC ASSET
FOR THE STATE AS HE WORKS
FORWARD TO WORK THE WORKING
LANDS. I'M A MULTIPLE
PRIORITIES. YOU SIR FOR THAT
AGENCY THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR PUBLIC SERVICE.
MATAMATA RAIDER NEXT WITNESS.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
LINE SEVEN SIX THE LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PABLO
GARZA WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF
DAVID SHOULD BE THERE ON. I'VE
KNOWN DAVID PERSONALLY FOR A
LITTLE OVER A DECADE AND- HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
HIM WHEN. HIS PRIOR ROLE AT THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS. AND JOSE DAVID
LOSE. AN INNOVATIVE THINKER
COLLABORATIVE. AS A COMPELLING
VISION KERR CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS. THE
RIGHT INDIVIDUAL FOR THIS JOB
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
BORDERLINE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
LINE FOR SEVEN TO LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS CHARLOTTE MITCHELL
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA FARMLAND TRUST
ENOUGH KNOWN THAT MR SPEAKING
FOR SOME TIME AND PREVIOUS
CAPACITY IS CERTAINLY IN OUR
WORK TODAY- CONSERVING FARMLAND
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THROUGHOUT THE REST THE
CALIFORNIA- AS THE ORGANIZATION
RULES COMMITTEE TO MAKE ITS
WITH CONFIRMATION OF. MR SHOULD
BE G. AND DEPARTMENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO LINE SIX TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M BILL
ALLEY- GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SACRAMENTO- WE
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF MR
SHOULD BE IS IN AS DIRECTOR
CONSERVATION TERMS I'VE KNOWN
HIM SINCE HE STARTED HIS CAREER
AS A PLANNER I WAS THE PLAN
DIRECTOR THE CITY OF DAVIS I'VE
SEEN. DAVID'S WORK FROM EARLY
ON HE CLEARLY HAD GREAT
APTITUDE AND SASS FOR THE
SUBJECT MATTER ANY BRINGS TODAY
THE STRENGTHS OBVIOUSLY OR IN
LAND USE THAT AGRICULTURAL
PRESERVATION THOSE THINGS BUT-
AS EVERYONE KNOWS THE WORK OF
DOGRA NOW CAL JAM IS THE
CONTROVERSIAL PART OF THIS
AGENCY. I THINK THAT THEY HAVE
A GOOD TEAM IN PLACE NOW TO
KEEP TURNING THE AGENCY AROUND
SO- I THINK DAVID WOULD CAME
COMES IN WITH EYES WIDE OPEN ON
THAT AND I'M SURE WE'LL CA TO
MAKE SURE. CAL JAM- CONTINUES
THE REFORM AND IMPROVEMENT THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN SUCH GREAT MATTER
THE. LAST THREE YEARS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR THAT
TESTIMONY OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SEVENTEEN LINE EIGHT ONE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ATKINS AND
MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATIE
PATTERSON AND I CURRENT
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER IF
YOU DAM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE EUROPEAN SUPPORT OF MR
SHOULD BE IN THE POINT IN THE
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION. AND COLLECTIVELY
WE ALL WISH AND TAKE THEM BACK
VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY THEWEALTH
OF THE DIRECTOR- WHAT IF HE
VIEWS ON OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE NC IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
WHEN IT COMES TO FARMLAND
PROTECTION THE AGENCY IN ASKING
SHARE THE MUTUAL. GOAL AND
PROTECTING THE MOST CRITICAL
PRODUCTIVE FARMLAND AND
RANCHLAND FROM UNNECESSARY
DEVELOPMENT EVERY YEAR FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND
ALOFT ABOUT THAT WITH FORTY
THOUSAND OF THOSE ACRES BEING
WALKED URBAN DEVELOPMENT THESE
METRICS UNDERSCORE THE JOB A
BIG AND A BIGGER HIGH IN ORDER
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY AN ECONOMY
THAT CONTRIBUTE ABOUT FORTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
COMMODITIES ANNUALLY. THE STATE
REQUIRES THE DIRECTOR TO BE
NAVIGATE CRITICAL ISSUES BUT BE
BOLD ENOUGH TO RECOMMEND
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO BRIDGE
THE RURAL URBAN DIVIDE WITH
YOUR BABY AND HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE WEALTHY TO BE A
BRIDGE BUILDER AND TO BE ON
YOUR FEET CRITICAL MISSIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU SEE THAT
YOUR SHOULD BE ONE OF THE LIKE
MINDED INDIVIDUALS LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING OUR COLLABORATION
WITH HIM THE DEPARTMENT STAFF
INCLUDING THE TRONG. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT.
THANK YOU NEXT WHAT PLEASE. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBERS SEVEN LINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND I'M
OF THE VICTOR ROME WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCE DEFENSE
COUNCIL AN RTC LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MR SPACEY AND IN
THIS ROLE ESPECIALLY AS WE SEEK
TO AS WE SAY COLLECTIVELY TO
TRANSITION CAL GEM. TO AN
AGENCY THAT PUTS PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY FIRST AND ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE LIVING IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT HIS NOMINATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE LINE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS KAREN
BERGER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION. DISTRICT AND OF
THE YEAR IF YOU WERE FOR THE
NINETY REFER COMPANY TO AROUND
THE STATE. WE ARE HERE THAT'S
ALL RECOMMEND IN ADDITION
BEACON DEPLOYMENT AND- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT LONG
TERM COMMITMENT THAT HE HAD THE
CONFIRMATION BUT IN PARTICULAR
WE REALLY APPRECIATE HAS
FOCUSED ON COMBINING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND- AND DOCTORAL
WORKING LANDS WHERE I REALLY
STRONG COMMITMENT TO
CONSERVATION AND WE FEEL LIKE
THAT ALONG WITH HIS ABILITY TO
BRING TOGETHER AND A COMMITMENT
TO BRINGING TOGETHER DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS TO CRAZY IN A
NIGHT INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
THAT MEET ALL OF OUR NEEDS. AND
GOING TO BE A CRITICAL PART OF
HIS WE IN THE DEPARTMENT SO WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF HAND
AND APPOINTED. THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. WHY NOT
EIGHTY. LINE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BACK IN MARKET BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK COALITION
FOR THE STATE'S LEADING TO STAY
AND ORGANIC AGRICULTURE
ORGANIZATION WE BELIEVE MR
SHOULD BE EASY AND EXPERIENCE
WORKING ON AGRICULTURAL
CONSERVATION AND FARM INDUSTRY
VIABILITY ISSUES WITH THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS. WE CAN THE PERFECT
FOR THE POSITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. BLIND
EIGHTY FIVE LINE EACH FIVE WE
HAVE YOUR LINE OPEN ONE MOMENT
HERE GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
INSURANCE AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS LUCAS
FRERICHS A MAP THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY OUT WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF PAYMENT YOU
MADE THE APPOINTMENT AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION. WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ACCOMPLISHING
YOUR GOALS AND DIRECTOR SHOULD
MASON IS ALREADY CONVENE
DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER
FOR PROTECTION OF BOTH
ECOLOGICAL AND ECONOMIC VALUE
OF OUR STATE'S NATIONAL WORKING
LAND. WE'VE ALSO WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH MR SAFAVIAN IN A
VARIETY OF HIS PAST CAPACITY
INCLUDING HIS INFORMATION.
WORKING WITH THE SACRAMENTO
AREA. LET ME ASK YOU KNOW WITH.
HE'S ME EXCUSE. I NEED TO ASK
YOU FOR THE- OF ORDERS IN ORDER
FOR IF YOU WOULD SLOW DOWN A
LITTLE BIT IN YOUR COMMENTS
IT'S GOOD YOU CAN TAKE YOUR TOP.
ABSOLUTELY SORRY ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU THAT. WE HAVE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH MR SHOULD
MAINTAIN A VARIETY IT'S PAST
CAPACITY. IT IS A PERMISSION
WORK WITH THE SACRAMENTO AREA
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS WORKING
WITH INTEGRAL INVOLVED IN THE
CREATION OF A REGIONAL
BLUEPRINT FOR FUTURE GROWTH.
ULTIMATELY WITH A MODEL THAT
LED TO THE ADOPTION OF SB THREE
THIRTY FIVES- IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TO
CONFIRM DAVID SHOULD BE DIDN'T
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION THANKS SO MUCH AND
HAVE A GREAT DAY. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS. IT IS
INTERNAL AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. YOU HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN A FEW MINUTES. I'M NOW GOING
TO TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE APPOINTMENT
AND WE WILL START RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. AND
SEEING NO ONE STEPPING FORWARD
LET ME TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THERE IS NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO MADAM
MODERATOR IT WAS LESS THAN A
FEW MINUTES I'M NOW COMING BACK
TO YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR- WITH THAT-
SENATOR RALPH. THE GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU OF MADAM SECRETARY
WILL CALL THE ROLL. MONEY HI MY
NAME AYE ROTH BIRTH ROTH AYE
WILK ALL RIGHT WILK AYE ATKINS
HI A CONCISE ON CALL I KNOW
WE'RE GONNA WE WERE TOLD WE
COULD CLOSE THE ROLE SO- FOUR
ZERO. WITH SENATOR BATES ABSENT
I CONGRATULATIONS. YOU ARE
CONFIRMED. AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING OKAY GOOD LUCK AND
AGAIN THANK YOU. WE WILL NEXT
GO TO- APPOINTMENTS FOR THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES ABUSE AND
WELCOME MISS MEREDITH J.
WILLIAMS DR WILLIAMS EXCUSE ME-
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN WAITING- I WOULD
LIKE TO OFFER YOU THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
ANYONE- THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU
OR THAT HAS. SPECIAL NOTE OF
SUPPORT FOR YOU AND THEN MAKE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS STATEMENT
YOU WOULD LIKE AND HEN WE'LL
GO RIGHT TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE FOR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
ARE WELCOME DOCTOR WILLIAMS. I
THINK WE NEED TO UNMUTE YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM FOR TOM AND MY
THANKS TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU ABOUT DGSE AND ABOUT
MY- VISION FOR CONTINUING TO
STRENGTHEN THE DEPARTMENT. MY
NAME IS MEREDITH WILLIAMS AND
I'M THANKFUL TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY JUST SEARCH.
BEFORE I GET STARTED LET ME
THANK THOSE WHO HAVE
STEADFASTLY SUPPORTED ME IN MY
WORK AND IN MY LIFE. TO MY
FAMILY OF CHOICE I HAVE BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE. AND I HAVE
CHOSEN WELL AND I HOPE YOU ALL
KNOW HOW GRATEFUL I AM. I WANT
TO THANK MY FAMILY LENORA HALL
ALISON LESLIE CARTER AND O'MARA.
BUT SPECIAL THING THIS GOES TO
MY PARENTS. MY FATHER WAS A
CHEMISTRY PROFESSOR AND MY
MOTHER TAUGHT. HELLO BLACK
STUDIES AND POLITICAL SCIENCE
IN MY WORK PUTS ME SQUARELY
BETWEEN THOSE TWO REALMS
ALTHOUGH MY FATHER HAS PASSED.
AS YOU CAN SEE MY MOTHER
CONTINUES TO FIGHT THE GOOD
FIGHT. AS WITH ALL APPOINTMENTS
THAT COME BEFORE YOU THIS
POSITION IS A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPONSIBILITY. YOU ARE ALL
AWARE OF DTS HE'S CHALLENGES.
WE WORKING THE KERRY
DISPROPORTIONATE POLLUTION
BURDENS AND EXPERIENCE ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES. THEIR SUFFERING
HAS BEEN MADE EVEN WORSE BY
COVERT NINETEEN. I'VE HEARD
FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
CONTINUE TO DIE OUT THE
DEPARTMENT'S COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES. I WANT.
YOU TO KNOW THAT I TAKE THESE
CONCERNS VERY SERIOUSLY. AS
DOES THEGOVERNOR. AS DOES THE
SECRETARY HAPPENED DOES US AND
AS THOSE ARE STAFF. YEAH I TAKE
IN THIS POSITION BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN THE TNC. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I BELIEVE IN OUR
MISSION TO PROTECT PEOPLE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA
FROM THE IMPACTS OF PAST
PRESENT AND FUTURE EXPOSURES TO
HARMFUL CHEMICALS. I BELIEVE IN
OUR STAFF WERE. WRONGLY
COMMITTED TO THAT MISSION. AND
I BELIEVE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
HELPING DGSE MEET THAT MISSION
ESPECIALLY SECRETARY BLUMENFELD.
AND LASTLY I BELIEVE BASED ON
MY INTERACTIONS THAT A WIDE
RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS ARE ALSO
PASSIONATELY COMMITTED TO THAT
MISSION. I WANT TO SEE US
FULFILL THAT MISSION BY TELLING
PEOPLE WHAT WE PLAN TO DO AND
THEN DOING. I WANT US TO
FURTHER OUR MISSION BERMAN
FORSMAN OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL LOS. I BELIEVE THAT IF
WE DO THOSE TWO THINGS AND
COMMUNICATE TRANSPARENTLY WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS WE WILL BE
ABLE TO BUILD MORE TRUST IN
DGSE. THE SCALE OF THE PROBLEMS
RELATED TO TOXIC CHEMICALS IS
MAURY. THAN WIDELY RECOGNIZED
YET CALIFORNIANS EXPECT. US TO
SOLVE THEM. I'M GRATEFUL TO
HAVE A ARE TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP TO TACKLE THOSE
PROBLEMS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR MONNING
LET'S START WITH YOU THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
THANK YOU. DIRECTOR
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU FOR.
INTRODUCING YOUR FAMILY TO
LISTEN I'M ADMIRING THAT WALL
HANGING BEHIND YOU AS WELL. WE
HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION THE
OTHER DAY- I THINK JUST FOR THE
BENEFIT OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
PUBLIC IF YOU COULD JUST UPDATE
ON THE WORK ON THE PHOTOVOLTAIC
HAZARDOUS WASTE RECYCLING.
UNITED HAD A CHANCE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS AND I'VE
APPRECIATED YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AS MANY OF THE
SOLAR PANELS THAT WERE
INSTALLED TEN TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS AGO ARE NOW AT END OF
LIFE AND LOOKING FOR A FINAL.
RESTING PLACE OF HE WILL IN IN
THE GOAL OF THE LEGISLATION OF
COURSE WAS TO. TRY TO PROVIDE
RECYCLING OF MATERIALS THAT ARE
RECYCLING AND DISPOSAL OF WASTE
PRODUCTS IN THIS. MANNER IS
HAZARDOUS WASTE BUT I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN SOME
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH AND COULD
YOU JUST PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE
MAY BE WITH AN UPDATE AND HAS
THAT STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH BEEN.
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MONNING AND THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME I WILL SAY THAT MY SPOKE
VERY TALENTED SISTER MADE THE
CALL BEHIND ME. I IN TERMS OF
THE FOLDABLE TECH REGULATIONS
I- OUR DEPARTMENT IS IN THE
HOME STRETCH OF ADOPTING THOSE
REGULATIONS WHAT THOSE RESIDENT
REGULATIONS WILL DO IS ENABLE
FOLKS TO TREAT. PHOTOVOLTAIC
MODULES ONCE THEY'RE AT THE END
OF LIFE AS UNIVERSAL RICK WASTE
RATHER THAN HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
RIGHT NOW THOSE MINERALS ARE
CONSIDERED HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
SO. OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S EASIER TO DISPOSE OF
THEM PROPERLY YET SAFELY- IN
TERMS OF A DELAY FROM CODED OF
THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW THAT LAW WAS QUITE BACKED
UP AND SO ALTHOUGH WE WENT
AHEAD WITH THOSE REGULATIONS
DAVE NEEDED A LITTLE EXTRA TIME
TO. DO THEIR FINAL REVIEW WE
EXPECT THAT REVIEW TO BE
COMPLETE BY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER FIRST WHICH MEANS THE
UNIVERSAL WASTE DESIGNATION
WILL BE IN EFFECT STARTING IN
THE NEW YEAR. IT DOES. COME UP
ADOPTED BY AWAY- WILL BEGIN OUR
OUTREACH PROCESS WE WILL
EDUCATE THE LOCALS. HAZARDOUS
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
HAZARDOUS WASTE HANDLERS AS TO
WHAT THE REGULATIONS MEAN AND
HOW TO- MANAGE THE PHOTOVOLTAIC
MATERIALS WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS
ARE ALL OF THE REGULATIONS AND
THEN WE'LL YOU KNOW WE'LL TRAIN.
KIND OF WORK FROM A STATE OR
CIRCLE OUT WE'LL GET OUR
INTERNAL FOLKS AND THOSE WHO
ARE MOST INTIMATELY A SOCIAL-
RESPONSIBLE FOR HANDLING THE
MATERIALS WELL TRAINED AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE OUT- TO BROADER AND
BROADER CIRCLES AND TO
HOPEFULLY GET TO CONSUMERS
WORKING PARTNERSHIP PERHAPS
WITH OTHER AGENCIES WHO HAVE A
BETTER CAN- CONSUMER INTERFACE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS ARE
AWARE OF WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
AT THE END OF LIFE OF THEIR
PHOTOVOLTAIC CELLS. WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOU'VE BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO MY OFFICE IN
MOVING THIS FORWARD. WE DID
COME A NUMBER OTHER SUBS BUT-
MADAM CHAIR I'M GOOD FOR NOW
AND AGAIN I JUST WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE. PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT- QUESTION I HAVE
FOR YOU IS AT. HOW ARE YOU
WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
DEPARTMENTS TRANSPARENCY AND
COMMUNICATION- WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AGRICULTURE AND
BEEN THERE THAT LONG BUT WANTED
TO CUT IT CONSEQUENCES AND I'VE
HEARD INSIDE STAKEHOLDERS GET
TO THE TABLE NOT AS SOON AS
THEY WOULD LIKE SO JUST CURIOUS
ON YOUR PROGRESS ON THAT. WHAT
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT ISSUE ON
A NUMBER OF FRIENDS SO I WOULD
SAY. AS THE IMAGE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AS A WHOLE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE
IS PUT FORTH A PROPOSAL. THAT'S
UNDER CONSIDERATION NOW TO PUT
A BOARDING PLACE TO PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT VENUE FOR
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME BEFORE A
BOARD RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENTS AND- GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DECISIONS
WERE MAKING AND SO. THAT'S BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WAS RECOMMENDED
BY THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL
AND STAKEHOLDERS FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AND THEN THEY'D
MINISTRATIONS STANDS BY THAT
PROPOSAL. IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
CAN CONTROL WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A NEW
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT STRATEGIC
PLAN WAS BUILT AROUND THESE
LONG STANDING CONCERNS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OF COURSE
FISCAL STABILITY GIVEN OUR
BECAUSE OUR- MONETARY FISCAL
CHALLENGES. SO WE DO NOT PLAN
WE'VE DONE THINGS LIKE-
COMMITTED TO HAVING MEASURABLE
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS THAT WE
CAN AND MAKE PUBLIC. THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE COMMITTING TO DO AND
ON OURWEBSITE WE WILL BE
LAUNCHING DASHBOARDS THE CHORE
PROGRESS AGAINST THOSE
COMMITMENTS AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO
COME TO US AND HOLD US
ACCOUNTABLE AND SAY. YOU
HAVEN'T DONE WHAT YOU SAID YOU
WERE GOING TO DO SO THAT'S JUST
ONE OF MANY THINGS- WE- AGAIN
FOLLOWING THE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL
AND OTHERS WE CONSOLIDATED OUR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
WITH OUR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND TRIBAL AFFAIRS PROGRAM INTO
ONE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THAT HELPS US AGAIN ENGAGE WITH
COMMUNITIES AND STAKEHOLDERS IN
WAYS THAT PROVIDE THE
TRANSPARENCY. THAT PEOPLE VERY
MUCH WANT. GREAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANSWER LOOKING FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU- SENATE ROTH THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM UM DR
CONGRATULATIONS. STRUTNER IN
RESUME I HAVE TO CONFESS THAT
I'M NOT SURE I COULD SPELL
PHYSICS IN HIGH SCHOOL OR
COLLEGE- ABOUT YOUR RESUME
CERTAINLY SPARKLES AND- I HAVE
TO SAY THAT I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBSERVE THE TSC
A- IN WESTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
IN THE SENATE DISTRICT TO OVER
THE YEARS SO. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
STRINGFELLOW AND YOU ALL WERE
ACTIVE AS AN AGENCY AND A
VARIETY OF OTHER SITES IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY INCLUDING MOST
RECENTLY. A ONE IN IN THE CITY
OF RIVERSIDE. AND AS YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE A CRITICAL ROLE TO
PLAY IN THE PROCESS AND YOUR
JOB IS EXTRAORDINARILY
CHALLENGING IN PARTICULAR IS.
IN TERMS OF THE ISSUES RAISED
BY MY COLLEAGUE AND THAT IS
WORKING WITH VARIOUS. COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS AN INTERNET MOST
pINITIALLY WAS A LITTLE BUMPY
WAS A COUPLE YEARS AGO. BUT DTS
SEE YOUR TEAM ROSE TO THE
OCCASION AND THE RESULT WAS OF
FRANKLY A VERY VERY
SATISFACTORY RESULTS OF FOR ALL
CONCERNED INCLUDING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY SO. I
HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTIONS-
IF GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY I WILL
MOVE YOUR CONFIRMATION AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. AND YOUR TEAM IN THE
FUTURE SO AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS
DR. THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH- WE
ARE GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC EYE AND I'M GOING TO
START. WITH SUPPORT TESTIMONY.
AND WE WILL START RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
WILL GIVE GIVE THIS PHONE
NUMBER THE TOLL FREE NUMBER.
FOR THOSE WHO MAY WANT TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY VIA
TELECONFERENCE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. WITH THE ACCESS CODE
EIGHT ONE ONE NINE NINE FOUR
THREE FOUR THOSE ARE GETTING
INTO THE QUEUE RIGHT NOW. OKAY
I SEE NO ONE IN OUR ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE WAITING TO
TESTIFY SO LET ME TAKE A LOOK
AT ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO
ONE THERE ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY- MATAMATA RAIDER WE
WILL COME TO YOU AND- TH QUEUE
UP THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF DR
WILLIAMS. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE
HAVE LINE FORTY NINE NINE FOUR
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU GO AHEAD. HI LANE FORTY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN FOR YOU
YOU MAY WANT TO CHECK YOUR MUTE
CREATURE. OKAY THAT LINE-
DISCONNECTED IT WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN LINE THREE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME
IS INGRID BROSTROM WHAT THE
CENTER ON RACE POVERTY ON THE
ENVIRONMENT HERE TO EAT. YOUR
FEET RECOGNIZES THE MANY
CHALLENGES THAT EACH YEAR FACE
THE- CHANGES THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN TO DGSE. SUCCESSFULLY
MEET MANDATE TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. I BELIEVE THAT DR
DIRECTOR WILLIAM RECOGNIZES
THESE CHALLENGES AS WELL AND IS
COMMITTED TO MAKING SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE DEPARTMENT-
DIRECTOR WILLIAM SUPPORT FOR
THESE NAY NEEDED REFORMS. SUCH
AS THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
BOARD IS Y. C. R. T. ACCORDING
HER CONFIRMATION TODAY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. CONTINUE WORKING
WITH A DIRECTOR WILLIAMS AND
HER STAFF TO MAKE THANK YOU SEE
AN AGENCY THAT WORKS FOR THE
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ALL TOO
OFTEN BEAR COME UP AFTER.
BURDEN AND I THINK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINETY THAT FLYING NINE ZERO
THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ON
CAP KEY WITH Q. CAPTAIN
DISSOCIATE SAT BEFORE YOU TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC BALANCE. HE WAS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR MEREDITH
WILLIAMS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. DR WILLIAMS HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO REACHING OUT AND
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
IN COLLABORATIVE WAYS TO
ENCOURAGE DIALOGUE
UNDERSTANDING PROBLEM SOLVING
AND RESPONSIVENESS WITHIN A
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS LONG BEEN
PLAGUED WITH CONCERNS REGARDING
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY TIMELINESS AND
RESPONSIVENESS. DURING THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF THE DOCTOR
WILLIAMS HAS GUIDED THE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD PROVIDE AMPLE
EVIDENCE OF HER ABILITY TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS. TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH WHILE
SEEKING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PROCESS IMPROVEMENT AND
EFFICIENCY OUR COMMITMENT TO A
MORE TRANSPARENT ACCOUNTABLE
TIMELY AND RESPONSIVE
DEPARTMENT IS EVIDENT AND FOR
THESE REASONS SEAT IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE DEADLINE EACH
THREE THE LINE IS OPEN. IT'S
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THE
SUBJECT MONGER WILL SEE ALL OF
THE INDUSTRIAL ENVIRONMENT
ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO AND- I
COULD TAKE JUST TWO SECONDS TO
SAY HELLO TO MY STATE SENATOR
SENATOR ATKINS AND SAY WHAT A
PLEASURE IT IS TO. HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE COMMENTS IN
FRONT OF YOUR COMMITTEE GOOD TO
SEE YOU TODAY. THANK YOU. I E.
A INDUSTRIAL BERMAN ALSO SEE
ASIAN IS ANY AND ORGANIZATION
EXISTING IN SAN DIEGO NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
MANUFACTURING COMPANIES AND- I
IN THAT REGARD- WE PROBABLY
DIDN'T PLAY CLOSE TO FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WE ARE VERY
MUCH- HONORED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR
WILLIAMS- OVER THE YEARS- I
WOULD DESCRIBE OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH- DOCTOR WILLIAMS IS- AS
ONE OF THE EXTREME
ACCEPTABILITY SHE HAS BEEN A
REGULAR PARTICIPANT THAT BY
EA'S ANNUAL CONFERENCE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CONFERENCE IN THE
SAN DIEGO REGION- SHE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN ACCESSIBLE FOR
QUESTIONS AND ISSUES THAT. ARE
INDUSTRY MEMBERS NEED TO RAISE
AND WE THINK THAT HER CALM AND
STEADY APPROACH- ARE EXACTLY
THE SKILL SETS NEEDED TO BE
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL IN THIS
POSITION- SO WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORTER CONFIRMATION AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO PROVIDE HIS COMMENTS TODAY.
MR MUNGER ALL GOOD HEAR YOUR
VOICE THANK SO MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE ONE NUMBER
FIFTY TWO THAT IS LINE FIVE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
MEDICARE MEYER WITH THE BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS AND
WE ARE HERE IN THE TO THE
ETHICS SUPPORT OF DR WILLIAM
JUST CONFIRMATION. WE'VE WORKED
WITH HER- ON BOTH THE INTEL IN
AN IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SAFER
pNUMBER OF YEARS. WE HAVE BEEN
IMPRESSED BY HER DEEP KNOWLEDGE
AND FORTHRIGHTNESS AND HER
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ON HARD
ISSUES HEAD ON. AND WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT SHE HAS THE VISION
COMMITMENT AND LEADERSHIP TO
PROTECT BOTH THE COMMUNITIES
AND CONSUMERS OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE WINE
TWENTY FOUR THAT IS LINE TWO
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ANDREA EVAN TURNER- I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR CLEAN WATER ACTION AND
MIGHT LIKE TO AND MY- BURKE DTS
FOR MOST OF MY CAREER TO
ADDRESS TOXIC CHEMICAL ISSUES.
AS PARTOF OUR WORK TO STOP
POLLUTION AT THE SOURCE AND- MY
EXPERIENCE WITH THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM WHICH
DR- WILLIAMS LED- FOR QUITE A
WHILE GOES BACK TO THE CAR
ENGINES INTO OVER THE YEARS WE
HAVE HAD A GREAT DEAL OF
EXPERIENCE INTERACTING WITH.
DOCTOR WILLIAMS AND WE HAVE
ALWAYS FOUND HER TO BRING
WISDOM AND SCIENTIFIC ACTING
INTO HER WORK AT DGSE. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY AND YOU'RE HEARING
IT FROM OTHERS AS WELL BUT THE
WILLIAMS IS THE CONSUMMATE
PUBLIC SERVANT SHE IS ACROSS TO
ALL OF THE STATE. TO COME THE
TABLE SHE IS PUBLICLY
ACCOUNTABLE AND SHE HAS SHOWN
BOTH A COMMITMENT AND AN
UNDERSTANDING OF ENVIRONMENTAL
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE THAT WE
BELIEVE HAVE TO IMBUE THIS
DEPARTMENT. AND WE THINK THAT
THESE CHARACTERISTICS ARE
ESSENTIAL AS DGSE UNDERGO
SCRUTINY AND REFORM IN MAKING
IT A MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
SUCCESSFUL AGENCY SO FOR THAT
REASON I AM VERY PROUD ON
BEHALF OF OUR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO SUPPORT DR WILLIAM. TODAY AS
THE LEADER TO BRING THE AGENCY
INTERNET AFFECTED FUTURE I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT IF YOU ARE THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COULD NOT
PARTICIPATE TODAY CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND THE CENTER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. AND
SO WE'RE ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
CONFIRM DUCKLING TODAY WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN
CALIFORNIA AND SHE IS A LEADER
THAT. CAN DO THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE-
NEXT WEEK. THE LINE IS SO TWO
THAT IS A SO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
SIXTY TWO. SORRY NEEDED THIS IS
BILL ALLEY- ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT OF DR
WILLIAMS CONFIRMATION THIS IS A
TOP AGENCY TO RUN AND WE THINK
SHE HAS THE INTELLIGENCE AND AS
NEEDED WHEN NEEDED THAT
TOUGHNESS TO DO IT WE RECOMMEND
TO YOUR CONFIRMATION TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER NINETY THREE LINE
AT NINE THREE THE LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER TEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ABSENT KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ON ENERGY. DR
WILLIAMS APPOINTMENT OF
DIRECTOR OF PTFE TODAY WE GOT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
HER FOR MANY YEARS AND ARE
CONFIDENT IN HER SCIENTIFIC AND
TECHNICAL ACCURATE EXPERTISE. I
WAS ALSO FOUND HER TO BE VERY
RESPONSIVE AND ACCESSIBLE EVEN
WHEN WE MIGHT NOT AGREE ON A
PARTICULAR ISSUE- SHOULDN'T AND
DOESN'T EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
APPOINTMENT AT A VERY CRITICAL
JUNCTURE PRETTY TASTY AS YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD. ON THEIR LONG
OVERDUE IN AFRICA UNDER WAIT
UPON THE DEPARTMENT FROM THE
GOVERNMENT THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS UNITE LET ME. GET THAT
THE SORRY SORRY EXCUSE. ME
EXCUSE ME. I KNOW TO I HAVE I
HAVE SORRY TO SAY THAT SO MANY
TIMES I REALLY NEED YOU TO.
DOWN FOR OUR STENOGRAPHER SO IF
YOU'LL GO BACK- IF YOU CAN'T GO
BACK A FEW SENTENCES ND START
OVER I'D REALLY APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. APOLOGY NOT A
PROFOUND WITH IT HAPPENED
RECORDED WORKING ON IT- YEAH I.
AM UP WE KNOW WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH DR
WILLIAM FOR MANY YEARS AND ARE
CONFIDENT AND HER APPETITE. IT
TECHNICAL ARGUMENT EXPERTISE.
SHE IS THE RESPONSETHAT SHE'S
ACCESSIBLE. AND CHEAPER RIGHT
PERSON FOR THE JOB TO REFORM
PTSD. AND THE AND TO PROTECT
THE MANY COMMUNITIES AND
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA COULD
TOXIC CHEMICALS THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH HER
AND ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT HER
APPOINTMENT TO AN APOLOGY. FOR
THE PAIN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I THINK WE UNDERSTOOD
YOUR COMMENTS APPRECIATED AND-
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE CAPTURE
EVERY WORD- CERTAINLY. I KNOW
THAT THE- CONFEREES REALLY A-
THE CALM. BECAUSE A LOT ME TELL
YOU. WHEN THEY GET A CONFIRMED
IT'S PROBABLY THE BEST DAY. AND
IT'S ALL WORK FROM THERE SO I
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR ARE
THERE OTHER WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
IF ZERO AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. YES NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION. LET ME COME BACK TO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. AND
I SEE NO ONE HERE WAITING TO
TESTIFY LET ME JUST TAKE A LOOK
AT ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NO
ONE THERE WAITING TO TESTIFY SO
MADAM MODERATOR I'M COMING BACK
TO YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE LINE TWO THREE THE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GO
AHEAD. HELLO OKAY HELLO MY NAME
IS ERIC ONE PLAYER IS I'M AN
SOCIAL JUSTICE GLOBAL FUNDING
WITHIN THE KAMALA IN THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY AND WE ARE
OPPOSING THE APPOINTMENT OF
MEREDITH WILLIAM. TO HEAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES.
YEAH COLLISION BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE OF THE LAX AND
INEFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP. FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND OUR CASE IN POINT IS
THE CONTINUED STRUGGLE TO
MITIGATE THE FORMER TOXIC
PEOPLE FIGHT AND BRAWLING. ALL
MY CHEVRON FOR THE COMMUNITY
HAD TO FIGHT MILLIONS YOU JUST
TO BE HEARD TO OUR DESIRES AND
WE CONTINUE TO AWAIT. THE
FINAL. SOLUTION TO A TWENTY
YEAR CONTRACT OPENSIDE DESPITE
MANY PROMISES AND NOW WE SEE A
SIMILAR PATTERN OF THE POLLUTER
DRIVING THE ISSUE AT THE
CLOSURE OF A CLASS ONE LANDFILL
OUTSIDE OF WOOD FLOORING. AND
THE COMMUNITY DESIRES BEING
LEFT TO THE SIDE. WE ALSO NOTE
THAT UPON TAKING THE. POSITION
THE SAME APPOINTEES WHO HAVE
BEEN THAT IN THE- AS WELL. IN
THE MOTHER'S CAMINO OF COLOR I
pWE COULD NOT MANY ARE. FOR AND
NOW WELCOME CITING THE INDUSTRY
OVER COMMUNITY HEALTH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TO OF MATAMATA. I
NEXT. WE HAVE THIRTY NINE LINE
THREE NINE THE LINE IS A. GO
AHEAD PLEASE NINE THIRTY NINE
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
IS THERE A LINE IF YOU WANT TO
YES WE HEAR YOU NOW PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARGARET
GORDON I'M WITH THE WEST
OAKLAND BOMMEL INDICATORS
PROJECT. THIS BILL HAS BEEN
HISTORY WITHIN DTS THE NOT OP
OP LYING- WILL BURST VIOLATIONS
AGAINST- POLLUTERS THE IMPACT
WITH OAKLAND AND POLITICALLY AS
OF RIGHT NOW. THE NEW TO STILL-
FACT THAT THEY HAVE HAD TWENTY
YEARS. I'M MORE TO MAKE THEM
UPGRADE MAP APPROVED WEST
OAKLAND AND WE'RE AT THE AND-
AS A THE STAGE WHERE IS THAT
AND NOT THE- COMMUNITY ANOTHER
BUSINESS HAVE SUED PDVSA. THAT
MAKE THEM TO COLLECTIBLES
OBLIGATION. AND I FEEL AS
THOUGH THEY HAVE NOT ENDED
TWENTY QUESTIONS THAT I'VE BEEN
ENGAGED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
WITHIN THE WEST OF SOME UNIQUE
AS OF AS THE STAFF OF THE WEST
OAKLAND BOB MILLER INDICATORS
PROJECT HAVE NOT BEEN DUE
DILIGENCE. AND THAT- MEREDITH
SHOULD NOT BE. APPOINTED TO
THIS POSITION. THANK YOU ARE
MATAMATA NECK WITNESS. WE HAVE
LINED UP SEVEN PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MEDICARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LOUISE ALL
METAL AND I GUESS I WILL
PROMISE I SAY AND I AM TWENTY
YEARS IN WORKING ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO HELP
WORK WITH THE PSC. YOU KNOW
THROUGH- NEARLY TWO DECADES-
WORKING WITH MARINE CORPS SINCE
WORKING WITH BARBARA BARBARA
LEAVE WITH DEBBIE RAPHAEL AND
I'VE HAD PLENTY OF
INTERACTIONS- WITH- WITH
DIRECTOR MEREDITH WILLIAMS- WE
AS AN ORGANIZATION- OF THE
FIFTY REQUIRED BY YOU MY NAME
AGAIN LEGAL MAIL- I HAVE- IS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS
CONSISTENTLY. FAILED TO DELIVER
YOU NEED TO BY MIDDLE OF
JUSTICE PROMISES THAT SHE HAD
STATED EVEN TO DATE- FENCE- THE
LAST AS I SAID- NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS THE DEPARTMENT HAS GONE
IN A CONSTANT DOWNWARD SPIRAL
YOU KNOW THE- OFFICE OF
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS THAT IT
HARDLY IT WENT FROM SIXTY
IMPROPERLY DID NEARLY LESS THAN
A DOZEN OF THEM. NOW HE HAS
NOTICED THAT YOU KNOW SHE WENT
FROM HAVING AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN IN AN OFFICE OF EQUITY NAY
AND IT SEEMS LIKE THEY CAN'T
EVEN GET THAT STRAIGHT YOU KNOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH ISSUES WE
ARE ONE OF THE THREE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE THAT
HAS A POCKET CLASS ONE.
LANDFILL AND I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR GENDER BLUMENFELD
THE SECRETARY AND I BELIEVE
THAT HE JUST MADE THE WRONG
CHOICE AND WE PRACTICAL
CONVERSATION WE DEAL ON A DAILY
ON A CONSISTENT BASIS WITH THIS
DEPARTMENT I BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
TAKEN OVER IT'S BEEN RUN OVER
BY THE INDUSTRY AND IT'S TIME
TO DISMANTLE IT. IT'S TIME TO
REBUILD IT AND IN YOU NEED AT
LEADERSHIP THAT BILL WASN'T PUT
THERE BY DEBBIE RUST BELT AT
SOMEBODY WHO CAME IN WITH
EXPERTISE ON ON GREEN CHEMISTRY
ON CONSUMER PRODUCTS WE GET
THAT DESPERATE FOR DECENT YOU
SHOULD DEFINITELY RUN RUN AT
THE- ONE OF THE PROGRAMS THERE
BUT SHE IS NOT HAVE THE
CHARACTERISTICS. THE LEADERSHIP.
NECESSARY TO TURN UP THAT
SHIPPED AROUND AND THIS. AND RE.
IT THAT'S NOT THE DIRECT WE
NEED TO SPEND. WE NEED TO LET
JUST STOP. AND WE DEFINITELY
NEED THE SO OF THE GOVERNOR AND
THAT IS THE SAME. WILL HAVE A
LOT OF BOTH REACHED BOTH OF
THEM I THANK YOU THE MAN.
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MAD MODERATE I KNOW WITNESS. WE
HAVE LINE EIGHTY EIGHT THAT IS
LINE EEK EEK PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS. ANGEL AND
ON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF GREEN
ACTION FOR HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. AND
REGRETTABLY I AM SPEAKING
TODAY. ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS
AND CONSTITUENTS IN COMMUNITIES
LOW INCOME AND WORKING CLASS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMMUNITIES. ACROSS THE STATE
TO. URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
NOMINATION OF ADOCTOR WILLIAMS
WHY ACTUALLY- LIKE DR OKAY
WILLIAMS I THINK IS WELL
INTENTIONED SHE IS MOST
DEFINITELY ACCESSIBLE WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW
SHE'S HARD WORKING. BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE AND RACISM AND DAILY
VIOLATIONS OF CIVIL RIGHTS
INCLUDING LANGUAGE ACCESS. IN
THE RIGHT TO MEANINGFUL. PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. CONTINUES AS WE
SPEAK RESIDENTS IN COMMUNITIES
ON THE FRONTLINES. FROM
TREASURE ISLAND WHERE LOW
INCOME PEOPLE LIVE ON TOP OF
RADIOACTIVE WASTE THANKS TO
DGSE. TO BAYVIEW HUNTERS POINT
AND HUNTERS POINT SHIPYARD AREA
THE KETTLEMAN CITY TO
BUTTONWILLOW TO WESTMORELAND TO
BROADLY TO LAYTONVILLE. URBAN
RURAL INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS ARE BEING POISONED. AND
THEY'RE BEING YOU DIFFICULT
FRIENDLY. THE LAST THING I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST SAY IT'S
JUST THIS MORNING. DR WILLIAMS
CONVEYED RESPONDED. AND LET US
KNOW THAT SHE AND THE AGENCY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO KEEP THEIR
COMMITMENT TO RESPOND TO THE
ECJ MOVEMENT'S DEMANDS TO NOT
USE KERN COUNTY'S RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY THE I. R.
PROCESS FOR DG SC'S DECISION
AROUND THE BUNDLE OF TOXIC DONE
PROMISES NEED TO BE CAPS CIVIL
RIGHTS NEEDS TO BE COMPLIED
WITH AND JUSTICE NEEDS TO
PREVAIL AND I JUST THINK
UNFORTUNATELY DR WILLIAMS IS
NOT THE RIGHT PERSON NOT TO SAY
SHE HAS MADE A GOOD EFFORT BUT
HE'S NOT THE RIGHT PERSON FOR
THIS JOB WE NEED BIG TIME
CHANGE. AND START. PROTECTING
PEOPLE NOT POLLUTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TEST.
TOPBETTA MODERATOR HI IS THERE
THERE FURTHER WITNESSES. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
THAT'S LINE AT NINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS SONNY A
LOT BUT IT'S FROM THE IMPAIR
VALLEY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION- WE'RE CALLING TO
OPPOSED THE APPOINTMENT OF
MEREDITH WILLIAMS THAT HE
THINKS HE AGENCY DIRECTOR. OUR
COALITION IS DEDICATED TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE EQUITY AND
JUSTICE OF OUR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE BORDER
REGION AND IMPERIAL COUNTY AND
AS YOU KNOW THE COMMUNITIES ARE
OPTING. OUT BEARING THE
DESPERATE AND NEGATIVE BURDEN
OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION-
WHICH THE- DEPARTMENT OVERSEAS
AND WE NEED LEADERSHIP THAT IS
DEDICATED TO WORK WITH LOCAL
EAGER PARTNERS TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS AND ENVIRONMENT OF
THESE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES-
OFTEN IN THE GRANT OFTEN LOW
INCOME YOU KNOW IMPERIAL
LIVING. IN VERY HIGH RATES OF
POVERTY AND THE OTHERS IN THE
CALL HAVE MENTIONED THE STATUS
QUO IS OPERATING WITH PRACTICES
EMBEDDED IN STRUCTURAL RACISM-
SO WE NEED LEADERSHIP THAT IS
TRULY RESPONSIVE- TO THE EACH A
LOCAL LEADERS THAT HAVE SHARED
CONCERNS. WITH HER APPOINTMENT
HERE TODAY SO I URGE YOU TO
LISTEN TO THEIR CONCERNS-
CAREFULLY UNFORTUNATELY THEN
PROBABLY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
COALITION WILL ALSO BE IN
OPPOSITION. FOR THE APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. PLEASE ENTER
ANSWERING MY IF YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME YOU MAY PROCEED. HE MET A
MODERATOR- I'M GONNA BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I IN LIGHT OF
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION. LET ME ASK DOCTOR
WILLIAMS IF TO START YOU AYE IF
THERE WERE QUITE A FEW COMMENTS
THERE FROM. FOLKS AND- I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK IF YOU WOULD LIKE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON
ANY OF THOSE. QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. FROM YEAH THANK YOU
FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY. I WOULD
SAY THESE ARE THE PRECISELY IN
THE CHALLENGE THAT IS THAT I
ALLUDED TO IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS. I AGREE WITH THE FACT
THAT WE. NEED TO CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN OUR ENGAGE. A WE TO
TAKE AGGRESSIVE STANCE. WHEN IT
COMES TO ENFORCEMENT IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE EARING
THESE BURDENS- UNFORTUNATELY
THE WHEELS OF GOVERNMENT
SOMETIMES MOVES SLOWLY WE ARE
MOVING OUT FOR INSTANCE- WITH
REGARD TO THE KERN COUNTY. KERN
COUNTY CIVIL RIGHTS CONCERN
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION WE
HAVE ENGAGED WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE ENGAGED
WITH THE COUNTY WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CIVIL RIGHTS AND
LANGUAGE ACCESS IN FACT. BERMAN
HAS ADOPTED A VERY FORWARD
LEANING LANGUAGE ACCESS POLICY
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO NOT ONLY
TO- IMPLEMENTING THAT POLICY
OURSELVES BUT USING THAT POLICY
TO GUIDE ACTIONS THAT ARE TAKEN
BY OTHER AGENCIES WITH. IN YOU
KNOW WITH WHICH WE- INTERACT
AND SO. I JUST REINFORCED MY
COMMITMENT THE SECRETARIES
CONFIRMED COMMITMENT- THE
GOVERNOR IS ALL ABOUT
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND WHEN.
AND THE DRIVING FORCE BEHIND
THAT IS EQUITY YOU KNOW HE CAME
OUT WITH CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND
TALKED ABOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND TALKED ABOUT. PLACES LIKE
IMPERIAL THAT IMPERIAL WE'RE
GOOD AT THE BURDENS ARE
TREMENDOUS AND WE HAVE TO. JUST
CONTINUE TO PUT OUR SHOULDER
AGAINST THE WHEEL AND KEEP
MOVING THE BALL FORWARD AND
THAT'S MY COMPLAINT. THANK YOU
DR WILLIAMS LET ME- BRING IT
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OUR
MOTION. THE SENATE ROTH I'M
SORRY WELL LET ME FIRST MAKE
THE MOTION TO CONFIRM THANK
YOU. IT WILL JUST MAKE A
COMMENT- YOU KNOW. IN GENERAL
WE TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THE
COMMENTS THAT. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC MAKE DURING THIS RULES
COMMITTEE HEARING AND THE
SUBMISSIONS THAT ARE PROVIDED
TO US. AND WHEN WE RECEIVE THEM
I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WE TAKE THOSE
SUBMISSIONS SERIOUSLY AND WE
LOOK INTO THEM. SO THAT WE TRY
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AND WE
TRY VERY HARD TO UNDERSTAND.
THE VARIOUS POSITIONS THAT ARE
PRESENTED WITH RESPECT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S. NOMINEES THIS IS
NOT A SLAM DUNK WIN WIN
NOMINEES ARE PRESENTED TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND NO ONE
SHOULD THINK IT IS BUT IN
LOOKING AT THE STAFF REPORT
THAT I HAVE IN FRONT OF ME IT
SAYS OPPOSITION NONE REPORTED.
AND IN FACT IT WAS NOT UNTIL
AFTER I MADE MY COMMENTS DR
ABOUT YOU BUT I RECEIVED A TEXT
FROM MY STAFF MEMBER WHO
INDICATED THAT A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION AND COME IN. JUST AT
THAT MOMENT I'M NOT SPEAKING TO
YOUR DOCTOR I'M SPEAKING TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND I
THINK TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE STILL ON THE
LINE. IF YOU HAVE ISSUES THAT
ARE OF CONCERN TO YOU ON THIS
APPOINTMENT OR ANY OTHERS THAT
COME BEFORE THE RULES
COMMITTEE. I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT ON YOU TO. PROVIDE
YOUR COMMENTS IF YOU CAN IN
ADVANCE SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU AND WE CAN
LOOK INTO THEM. AND WE CAN HAVE
AN INTELLIGENT CONVERSATION
WITH THE NOMINEES AT THE
GOVERNOR PUTS FORWARD. IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO ANALYZE WHAT YOU SAY TO US
IN PUBLIC COMMENT AND DEAL WITH
THAT. IN THE TWO OR THREE
MINUTES THAT YOU HAVE AND IN
THE TIME THEN THAT WE HAVE. TO
DEAL WITH THE NOMINATION SO
MATTER PRO TEMAS TO MAKE THE
MOTION TO CONFIRM AND I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT MY COMMENTS
ARE ON THE RECORD SO THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LISTENING
WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION. I
UNDERSTAND THE POSITION THAT
WE'RE IN. I WILL COMMIT TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT- FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I WILL I WILL WILL
WORK WITH THE DOCTOR. AND THE
T. S. C. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED.
ISSUES OF STAKEHOLDER
RESPONSIVENESS- ISSUES OF
RESPONSIVENESS TO THE NEEDS IN
THE COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT
METAL PROTEIN THANK YOU FOR
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH
SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- I'D LIKE TO JUST TO
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH US OF
SENATOR ROTH- I JUST LEARNED
FROM MY STAFF- IS WELL ABOUT
OPPOSITION AND- IT IS HELPFUL
FOR US TO HAVE. CONCERNS
VOICED. AT LEAST WITH ENOUGH
TIME TO. LOOK INTO IT MAYBE
FORMULATE OUR QUESTIONS FOR ANY
CANDIDATE WHO COMES FORWARD.
BUT BEING SENSITIVE TO THE
CONCERNS RAISED THE COMMONALITY
OF ALL THOSE WHO WEIGHED IN.
WAS AN ISSUE OF. ENVIRONMENTAL
RACISM OF TOXIC DUMPS AND AS WE
KNOW THE HISTORY OF THIS STATE
THE HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY AND
A GLOBALLY TOXIC WASTE OR TOXIC
PER. IS MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
LOCATED NEAR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR I THINK SOME OF THE
STRUCTURAL DYNAMICS THAT ARE
NOT THE FAULT OF TODAY'S
CANDIDATE ALSO INCLUDE BUDGET
PRIORITIES FOR STATE ACTION AND
AS WELL AS HOLDING RESPONSIBLE
INDUSTRIES ACCOUNTABLE- FOR
REMEDIATION AND IDEALLY FOR
PREVENTION IN THE FIRST PLACE-
SO WHEN I HEAR FROM. THE
DIRECTOR AND IN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH HER SHE
SHARES THOSE CONCERNS AND
COMMITMENTS WE FACE A
PARTICULARLY TOUGH TIME NOW
WITH COVERT NINETEEN THE IMPACT
ON THE STATE'S BUDGET. AND OUR
ABSOLUTE DEPENDENCE. ON SUPPORT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT HAS NOT BEEN FORTHCOMING
DUE TO INACTION. IN CONGRESS IN
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE. TO HELP
SUPPORT STATES AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO FULFILL EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS AND INDEED TO LOOK
TO EXPANDING OUR CAPACITY TO
RESPOND TO THE VERY CONCERNED
SO WELL I THINK THOSE WHO WAIT
IN. AND UNDERSTAND THE
SINCERITY OF THEIR CONCERNS. I
THINK THE PROBLEM CITED
ACTUALLY GO BEYOND. ANY
CULPABILITY OF THIS NOMINEE- OR
PERHAPS OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
REQUIRE STRUCTURAL REFORM AT
THE STATE LEVEL IN TERMS OF THE
PRIORITIZATION THAT IS THOUGHT
AND I WOULD JUST CONCLUDE BY
ENCOURAGING THE DIRECTOR WHO'S
ON THE FRONT LINE OF THIS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE SECRETARY IN THE
GOVERNOR ARE KEPT IN REGULAR-
COMMUNICATION ON THE NEEDS OF
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE
MAY BE BUDGET ACTION REQUIRED
OR LEGISLATIVE ACTION REQUIRED.
SO WITH THAT- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU SENATOR
MINING- LET ME CONCLUDE WITH
THIS I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO SPOKE TODAY IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. THAT IS
AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
PROCESS AND I WOULD SAY THAT.
THE SENATE OUT MUCH TO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR ROTH AYE THIS IS NOT A
RUBBER STAMP WE TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY AND WHAT WE HAVE DONE
IN THE PAST AND WHAT WE WILL
DO- WORKING WITH THE DIRECTOR
AND CERTAINLY THE SECRETARY. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD- MY STAFF ARE.
ON MANY OCCASIONS WHEN THERE IS
OPPOSITION TAKE NOTES WE HAVE.
THE MINUTES FROM OUR
STENOGRAPHER. TO OUTLINE THE
ISSUES OF CONCERN AND WE WILL
COMMUNICATE WITH THE DIRECTOR
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO PUT
THAT IN WRITING AND TO FORWARD
IT. AND IT ALSO TO TALK ABOUT
THE ROLE THAT WE PLAY IN
OVERSIGHT- IT N. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND WE HAVE DONE THAT
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENT
DIRECTORS. WE HAVE HELD
MEETINGS- AFTER TO OUR TO GO
OVER ISSUES OF CONCERN AND TO.
MY COLLEAGUES SENATOR MINING'S
POINT- SOME OF THESE
DEFICIENCIES ARE. A SYSTEMATIC
I THINK IN TERMS OF HISTORY- I
THINK THAT IS WHY I THINK THE
GOVERNOR I BELIEVE TRIES TO
MAKE THE APPOINTMENTS WITH THAT
IN MIND IN TERMS OF THE
REPRESENTATION TO COVER ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN IGNORED- I'M
GOING TO ASSUME THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY THE CASE HERE BASED
ON SOME OF THE COMMENTS I HEARD
FROM SOME ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT. SO WE WILL COMMUNICATE
WITH YOU FURTHER- DIRECTOR AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE HAVING AN ONGOING.
DIALOGUE AND THAT WE ACCEPT OUR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OVERSIGHT
MONITORING BUT ALSO AS IT COMES
TO BUDGETARY ACTIONS- IN TERMS
OF WHAT MIGHT BE NEEDED- AS IT
RELATES TO SOME OF THE
ENFORCEMENT ISSUES WHICH WAS
OUTLINED IN AND IN OUR- STAFF
FOR A REPORT AND NOTES RELATED
TO SOME OF THE ISSUES. THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS HISTORICALLY HAD
AND WE HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY
THERE SO. HAVING SAID THAT I.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION. AND MADAM SECRETARY WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BATES WILL
BE JOINING US SHORTLY AND I WAS
NOT UNDER THAT IMPRESSION
BEFORE SO. WEWILL LEAVE THE
WORLD BUT FOR NOW WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. IF MINING HI
MONNING AYE ROTH AYE ROTH AYE
WILK AYE WILK AYE ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE IT IS FOR VOTES TO
CONFIRM AND WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR BATES
AND- DIRECTOR CONGRATULATIONS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON ALL ISSUES WHETHER THEY
ARE ISSUES IN NEED OF
IMPROVEMENT ARE AT WORK THAT
YOU HAVE DONE THAT WE CAN ALL
BE PROUD OF SO CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WE ARE GONNA I'D TAKE A FEW
MINUTES ARE. OF A LITTLE BIT OF
A BREAK- FOR ARSON ORDER FOR
WHO BY. MAY NEED A FEW MINUTES
AS MAY WE AND SO WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU IN A FEW MOMENTS.
COMMITTEE BACK INTO SESSION.
AND FORGIVE US FOR THAT SMALL
BIT OF TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY WE
ARE NOW ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE NEXT TWO APPOINTMENTS WHICH
ARE FOR THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
MISS STEPHANIE KOLODNY
CLENDENIN CLENDENIN PLEASE
FORGIVE ME IF I GOT THAT WRONG
AND FOR THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
MISTER STERLING PRICE LET ME
WELCOME BOTH OF YOU LET ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AND I WILL ASK THAT EACH OF YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE. A
STATEMENT THANK ANYONE THAT
MIGHT BE- WITH YOU OR OF
PARTICULAR SUPPORT FOR YOU. AND
AFTER EACH OF YOU'VE GIVEN YOUR
INTRODUCTIONS AND STATEMENTS I
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS AND WE WILL WE WILL
HEAR BOTH OF YOU AT THE SAME
TIME AND THE QUESTION WILL
EITHER BE DIRECTED AT ONE OF
YOU ARE. BOTH OF YOU TO RESPOND
TO- IF YOU WOULD LIKE. AND SO
WITH THAT DIRECTOR. CLENDENIN I
WILL ASK IF YOU WILL START AND
THEN I'LL MOVE TO- THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR PRICE. WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S
AN HONOR TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS THE SENATE CONSIDERS
CONFIRMING ME AS DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE IF YOU FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WHO ARE ATTENDING
VIRTUALLY TODAY AND THANK THEM
FOR THEIR LOVE AND SUPPORT RAFI
YEARS FIRST OF ALL MY LOVING
HUSBAND OF THIRTY YEARS DAVID
CLIMB DIçN MY PARENTS RON AND
JENNY BOWLES MY TO DO. BROWN
AND BRITNEY I AM PROUD TO HAVE
ALSO CHOSEN PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREERS AFTER COMPLETING THEIR
MASTER'S DEGREES NOT SACRAMENTO
STATE UNIVERSITY I'M BROWN IS
NOW SERVING AS AN ASSOCIATE
BUDGET ANALYST AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IN
BRINGING AN ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTIST AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION. MY
BROTHER AND MY DAUGHTER AND MY
AUNTS AND UNCLES AND SEVERAL
FRIENDS AS WELL ARE ATTENDING
FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIANS
TODAY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEW SIMON SECRETARY
GALLEY FOR THEIR CONFIDENCE IN
ME IN ACCORDING TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE CALIFORNIA
IN THIS CAPACITY. I'D ALSO BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T RECOGNIZE
OUR TEAM MEMBERS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
IT TRULY HAS BEEN AN HONOR FOR
THE LAST FIVE YEARS TO SERVE
BOTH AS CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND DIRECTOR AND D. S. AND TO
LEAD SUCH A DEDICATED AND
PROFESSIONAL TEAM OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK EVERY DAY.
WITH CARE AND COMPASSION
TOWARDS SERVING ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS INDIVIDUALS LIVING
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
THE WORK THAT WE DO IS
EXTREMELY REWARDING AND THERE
ARE MANY CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE CONTINUE
TO WORK TO ADDRESS. SUCH AS
ADDRESSING THE INCREASING
DEMAND FOR OUR SERVICES AND NEW
AND INNOVATIVE WAYS. ENHANCING
PATIENT AND STAFF SAFETY
INCREASING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION ACTIVITIES INCREASING
OUR DATA COLLECTION ANALYSIS
AND RESEARCH ACTIVITIES TIED.
AND RESPOND TO EMERGE TRENDS
OUR PATIENTS POPULATION AND
MOST RECENTLY RESPONDING TO ONE
OF OUR GREATEST CHALLENGES KOBE
NINETY. THE DS H. TEAM HAS
WORKED. TO IMPLEMENT INFECTION
CONTROL AND OTHER MEASURES AND
MAKE MODIFICATIONS TO OUR
SYSTEM OF CARE TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT SIX SEVEN NINETEEN ON
THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE. AS
MORE IS LEARNED ABOUT THIS
DISEASE AND WE CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE AND A BOMB TO RESPOND
TO CHANGING GUIDANCE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES. I AM VERY PROUD
OF THE DS SIXTEEN WHO CONTINUES
TO BE DEDICATED AND RISE TO THE
CHALLENGE DESPITE THE PERSONAL
RISK THAT MANY OF THEM FACE. AS
WE WORK TOGETHER TO MEET THE
NEEDS FOR CALIFORNIANS WE SERVE
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM. AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO MISTER PRICE
WELCOME. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
THE SENATORS IT'S AN HONOR TO
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TO YOU TODAY AS THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR APPOINTEE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY WIFE JOSEPHINE TWISTED
MY GREATEST SUPPORTER MY
DAUGHTERS ARIANNA ANNALISA AND
OF COURSE MY DAD STERLING MY
LATE MOTHER JANET- UNDERWAY
DURING SUPPORT AND SACRIFICE
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE AND CAREER.
BEGAN MY CAREER WITH THE STATE
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS AGO AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH NOW
THE DEPARTMENTS AND HOSPITALS
AS A SOCIAL WORK INTERN AND
LATER A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER. I SERVED IN A
VARIETY OF MANAGERIAL AND
EXECUTIVE POSITIONS MOST
RECENTLY AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ATASCADERO STATE HOSPITAL SO
MY APPOINTMENT AS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. AND PASSIONATE ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES FOR OUR DEPARTMENT
AND THE WELFARE OF OUR PATIENTS
AND TEAM MEMBERS I'M HUMBLED BY
YOUR. SUPPORT AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY. OF GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED A SENATOR ROTH YOU
WANNA START. THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM LET ME JUST SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU BOTH. I
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
BUT I WANT TO NOTE THAT THE- AS
YOU WELL KNOW THE OPERATION OF
ANY HOSPITAL SYSTEM WHETHER
IT'S A MENTAL HEALTH HOSPITAL
CENSUS TO MORE AN ACUTE CARE
SYSTEM BOTH PRIVATE OR PUBLIC.
IN THIS CODE NINETEEN
ENVIRONMENT IS EXTRAORDINARILY
CHALLENGING. WHETHER IT'S
TRYING TO FIND P. P. E. THAT NO
ONE HAS OF TRYING TO ALLOCATED
TRYING TO DEVELOP SANITATION
PROTOCOLS AND ALL THE REST TO
KEEP. BOTH STAFF AND THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR. A
SAFE AND HEALTHY VERY VERY
DIFFICULT SO LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
YOUR CONFIRMATION IF PERMITTED
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
PLEDGING TO YOU TO. WORK WITH
YOU AS A MEMBER OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO. TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE RESOURCES AND THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO DO. YOU'RE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT JOB. AND
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
THOSE THAT YOU WERE CHARGED
WITH PROTECTING SO. WITH THAT
MAN APPROACHED HIM THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU BROWN PRO
TEM AND CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU
BOTH ON ON YOUR APPOINTMENTS SO
QUICK QUESTION I HAVE IS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE STAFF
VACANCY RATES ARE ARE ARE
RELATIVELY HIGH SO I'M CURIOUS
IN TERMS WHAT ARE THEIR
STRATEGIES YOU GUYS ARE
EMPLOYING TO FILL THOSE AND IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING FOR MY
STAFF. THAT ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS YOU'RE USING A LOT OF
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS THAT IF AB FIVE IS
AFFECTED THAT FOR IF FOR SOME
REASON THEY ARE EXEMPT AND IF
SO HOW SO AND WITH THAT I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR RESPONSE. THANK
YOU- ALSO I'LL START BY. SAYING
GIVE COMMENTS ABOUT- THAT IS
STOPPING I'M IN OUR HOSPITALS
AYE WE EMPLOY A WIDE VARIETY
AND THE PARENTS AND STAFF-
CLASSIFICATIONS RODDER
HOSPITALS. AND WE DO HAVE-
CHALLENGES ARE WITH HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IT'S- IT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND THE NATION THERE
IS SHORTAGES OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS I'M IN MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND SO WE
JUST LIKE MANY OTHER SYSTEMS I
DO HAVE CHALLENGES IN
RECRUITING. I MEAN.
PROFESSIONALS AND TO OUR
SYSTEM. I DO WANT TO SAY THAT.
WE LOOK FOR EVERY OPPORTUNITY
WE CAN. TO FIND INNOVATIVE AND
CREATIVE WAYS TO RECRUIT
INDIVIDUALS- WE ALSO PARTNER
WITH AND EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND TO OFFER
INTERNSHIPS AND FELLOWSHIPS I
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
VERY MUCH FOR THE FUNDING WE
RECENTLY RECEIVED IN THE LAST
TIME. AB I THINK WAS TWO YEARS
AGO TO. EXPAND OUR OR
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN TRAINING
PROGRAM AT ATASCADERO AND THEN
WE ALSO RECEIVE FUNDING TO
ESTABLISH AND PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCY PROGRAM. AT OUR STATE
AND OUR HOSPITAL IN NAPA IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH TO IT THROUGH
UNIVERSITY SO WE ARE
CONSISTENTLY ALWAYS OPEN AND
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
EXPAND OUR RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING OF. PROFESSIONALS I'M
HERE IN THE STATE OF OUR
SYSTEM- WE I DO. HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING. YOU CONTRACTORS TO
FILL SOME OF OUR WHEN WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO. RECRUIT CIVIL
SERVICE ARE SUFFICIENT
QUANTITIES OF SUCH CIVIL
SERVICE TO OUR CLASSIFICATIONS
SO WE DO UTILIZE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS MANY OF THEM HAVE
WORK IN OUR SYSTEM AND NOW OR-
DECIDED TO LEAVE THE SYSTEM GO
BACK AND SOMETIMES THEY DO COME
BACK ON AS TIME TRACTORS. WHILE
THEY'RE WORKING ON THE WORK-
WITH US FOR SOME TIME AND SO I
HAD WITH RESPECT TO EIGHTY FIVE
AND THE STATUTE ITSELF DID HAVE
SOME- EXEMPTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT. AND I UNFORTUNATELY AM
NOT AN EXPERT IN THIS AREA
RIGHT OUT OF THERE WERE SOME
SPECIFIC EXEMPTIONS WITH SOME
OF OUR CLASSIFICATIONS I JUST
DON'T RECALL OFF THE TOP OF. MY
HEAD WHICH ONES IT. DEAD EXAMS.
EIGHT WHY WOULD NO AB FIVE SO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ME ON
THAT BUT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
FOR YOUR ANSWER NO LOOKING
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YEAR-
CONFIRMATION WHEN CENTER ROTH
MAKES THE MOTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MY
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU
ON ON YEAR APPOINTMENTS BUTPERHAPS MORE APPROPRIATELY
MONEY APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
CAREERS OF SERVICE I DID HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
ACQUAINTED WITH- CHIEF DEPUTY
PRICE WHEN HE WAS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT ATASCADERO STATE
HOSPITAL IN MIAMI SEVENTEENTH
SENATE-DISTRICT. I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR THEIR-
SEVERAL TIMES IN A TEN SOME OF
THE COMMUNITY EVENTS THERE- BUT
I'M WELL AWAREOF THE CHALLENGE
IN TERMS OF CAPACITY AND KERR
IN TERMS OF INFRASTRUCTURE OF
SOME OF THESE. KNEELING
INSTITUTIONS IN TERMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE HAD SOME
GOOD CONVERSATIONS I DID WITH
BOTH OF YOU- MAYBE A CHANCE
JUST TO ADDRESS A LITTLE BIT
MORE THE CHALLENGE OF COVERT
NINETEEN I KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
STATE HOSPITAL TWELVE PATIENTS
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE IN A
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN STAFF ARM
WHAT. WHAT ARE THE RESPONSES TO
THAT IN. PROTOCOLS TO TRY TO
PROTECT OTHER PATIENTS AND
STAFF THANK YOU. I CAN START
AND THEN- OFFER AS WELL AS DR
PRICE SOME OPPORTUNITY AS WELL
TO- ADDRESS THE QUESTION- AND
BUT ALL THE MAINFRAME IT I JUST
KIND OF GENERALLY AND THEN GIVE
HIM AN OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN
AS WELL I AM SO THEY
DEPARTMENT- HAS. SINCE MARCH
BEEN WORKING VERY TIRESOME AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS AND TOWARDS-
IMPLEMENTING INFECTION CONTROL
MEASURES AND MANY OTHER
MEASURES IN ORDER TO. RESPOND
TO COME IN NINETEEN AND DUE TO.
REALLY DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN ADD TO TRY TO PREVENT THE
INTRODUCTION OF KOBE NINETEEN
INTO OUR SYSTEM I WE VERY
QUICKLY RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WAS
AN EMERGENCY AND COULD VERY-
VERY QUICKLY I HAD BECOME A
PROBLEM FOR OUR OUR SYSTEM AND
PARTICULARLY AFTER SEEING. WHAT
HAPPENED IN A SEATTLE IN THE
CONVALESCENT FACILITY AND IN
THAT I'M STATE AND AS
RECOGNIZING THAT OUR SYSTEM IS
VERY SIMILAR TO- OUR OUR LIVING
ENVIRONMENTS AND OUR HOSPITAL
SYSTEM ARE VERY SIMILAR TO
CONVALESCENT FACILITIES AND
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES- WE
ARE VERY QUICKLY. ACTIVATED OUR
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER WE
COLLABORATE ON A DAILY BASIS
AND WE NEED EVERY MORNING TO
LEARN FROM THE EXPERIENCES OF
EACH OF OUR HOSPITALS AND TO
WORK ON POLICIES PROCEDURES ADD
TO. REVIEW THE CHANGING
GUIDANCE TO IMPLEMENT THAT
CHECK THE NEW PROTOCOLS AND THE
NEW GUIDANCE- WE YOU KNOW HAD
IMPLEMENTED- SCREENING FOR ALL
OF OUR STAFF COMING INTO OUR
HOSPITALS WE HAD I HAD
UNIVERSAL MASKING OVERSTAFFED.
WE ARE HAVE PROVIDED MASSPORT
PATIENTS WE HAVE TESTING
STRATEGIES AND PROTOCOLS FOR
BOTH OUR STAFF AND OUR PATIENTS
AS WE HAVE IT PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING THAT THE GUIDANCE IS
ASKED US TO DO OUR RECOMMENDED
THAT WE DO WE ARE WORKING VERY
HARD. TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE ARE
FOLLOWING NOT GUIDANCE WE ALSO
HAVE BEEN PARTNERING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE HEALTH CARE
MIRED IN SECTIONS TEENS ARE
WIND WE HAVE HAD AND THE
OPERATE TO HAVE THEM COME OUT
AND REVIEW TO SEE IF THERE IS
AN ADDITIONAL. ACTIONS THAT WE
CAN TAKE. DURING THAT YOU KNOW
A- NSTP RIGHT AWAY ACCESS
OUTSIDE SITTING IN IN DA STAYS.
ZERO EVERYTHING WE NEED IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CANNOT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS A VIRUS
THAT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
CONTAIN AND SO WE HAVE HAD-
SOME OUTBREAKS. AND YOU'RE
ALWAYS WORKING VERY HARD TO
EVALUATE FROM EACH OPERATE
INDETERMINATE THERE'S
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT WE CAN
LEARN AND IMPLEMENT ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM TO TRY TO AVOID ANY
FUTURE OUTBREAKS. AND I'LL GET
YOU TAPPING DR PRICE
OPPORTUNITY. AND THANK THANK
YOU. SO WE ALSO SHOW FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING THAT WE REALLY
HAD TO STAY AHEAD OF- THE VIRUS
IS BEST AS WE COULD AND LEARNED
EVERYTHING WE COULD ABOUT IT-
SO WE GET A LOT OF RESEARCH AND
AS SUCH RECTOR CLENDENIN
MENTIONED WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THEIR- HEALTH CARE
ASSOCIATED INFECTIONS- PROGRAM
EXPERTS- TO GUIDE US THROUGH
OUR REFUGEE POLICIES AND
RESPOND. AS QUICKLY AS WE COULD
YOU KNOW SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT-
THE TWO WAYS A VIRUS WAS GOING
TO GET INTO OUR HOSPITALS WAS-
THROUGH- STAFF COMING IN AND SO
IS- DIRECTOR CLINTON MENTIONED
WE STARTED- CASTING A STAFF
FOR- SYMPTOMS- ENTRY EVERY DAY
AND WE CONTINUE TO DO SO WE
ALSO KNEW THAT- NEW PATIENTS
COMING IN- WERE- GOING TO BE A
POTENTIAL- OF. A PROBLEM AND-
SO WE MOVED TO SUSPEND-
EMISSIONS FOR A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AND THEN SLOWLY REOPENED
THEM AS WE WERE WORKING WITH-
THE PRISONS AND THE JAILS- TO
DO IT IN A SAFE MANNER- SO EVEN
TODAY WE ARE WHEN WE KICKING
YOU EMISSIONS WEEK COHORT I
KNEW IT MISSIONS TOGETHER-
BASED ON THE GUIDANCE THAT
WE'RE RECEIVING EVERY ALSO TEST
PATIENTS ARE ON DAY ONE AND
THAT DAYS FIVE TO SEVEN AND DAY
FOURTEEN. A SO- AND WE'VE ALSO
WORKED OUT WITH- REFERRING- IN
JAILS AND PRISONS TO TEST
BEFORE THEY THEY SEND THE
PATIENT SO WE WERE TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KNOW WHAT
IS COMING IN OUR DOORS TO
PROTECT OUR STAFF AND OUR
PATIENTS- WE ARE WORKING VERY
HARD AND MAINTAINING AND THAT
EDUCATING- THEIR PATIENTS AND
STAFF ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND- THE
PROPER- DONNING AND DOFFING. OF
THE TPP ARE. WE ARE VERY VERY
SOON AND IF THE STOCK IT IS
CENTER ROSS MEASURE. THAT PP
FORGET TO OBTAIN SO WE- THE I.
N. Y. AGE FOR HE HE'S I'M I'M
GOING TO SAVE WE MAINTAINS US.
SO. TO THE STATE SO THAT'S
WORKING WORKING VERY. WE ALSO
QUICK TO HELLO FOR OURS WILL
YOUR INSIDE. IN THIS AS WE IN
THE SO THAT WE COULD BE THE-
AND IN MAY SOCIAL THIS. SO YOU
KNOW WE MAY WE DID MANY MANY
MANY OTHER THINGS AND I COULD
YOU KNOW COULD PROBABLY RIGHT
AFTER ALL AFTERNOON THANK YOU A
LOT OF THEM I APPRECIATE THEM A
LOT. THE COMPREHENSIVE EFFORTS
I. ANY ANY SENSE OF WHY PATTON
HAD SUCH A HIGH. HAS HAD SUCH A
HIGH INCIDENCE OF INFECTION.
WELL I THINK THAT- IT'S PRETTY
REFLECTIVE OF THE AMOUNT OF
COMMUNITY SPREAD THAT THEY HAVE
HAD THEIR AS WELL SO THAT'S THE
GIST OF. THE NONTECHNICAL
OBSERVATION BUT SO WE THOUGHT
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THAT AND-
A RIVERSIDE- COUNTY HOUSE OF A
LOT OF. SPREAD AND- COMMITTEE
TRANSMISSION AND- WE MAY BE
SEEING THAT. GREAT WELL THANK
YOU AND AGAIN ON. RESHAPE BOTH
OF YOU IN IN THE FRONT LINE
EMPLOYEES ON YOUR TEAMS- DO
AMAZING WORK EACH AND EVERY DAY
SO I HOPE YOU'LL CONVEY MY
THANKS TO THEM WITH A VERY-
DIVERSE AND COMPLEX PATIENT
POPULATION SOME PRESENTING WITH.
HE SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
SOME WITH A COMBINATION OF
CRIMINAL. CONDUCTEUR FACING
CRIMINAL CHARGES SO- WE
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOUR TEAM TO
STAY SAFE AND HEALTHY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR MINING AND- WE WILL NOW
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- I
WILL START WITH MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT- FOR THE PUBLIC I WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW- WE WILL BE.
LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT TO
THREE MINUTES- PER SPEAKER AND
SO THAT IS ANTICIPATING- SOME
ADDITIONAL FOLKS CALLING IN
ALSO. IN TERMS OF THE TIME
LIMIT FOR THE COMMITTEE SO
THREE MINUTES- AND WE WILL KEEP
TRACK OF THAT BUT FIRST I'M
GONNA START WITH- MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THAT MIGHT BE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I
ACTUALLY SEE NO ONE HERE FROM
THE PUBLIC TO TESTIFY- AND
WE'RE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT LET
ME TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. OKAY SEEING NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MATAMATA
RAIDER I'M GONNA COME TO YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
AGAIN. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD IF YOU ARE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE YOU MAY
NEED TO PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
LINE NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE ONE NINE THE LINE IS
OPEN. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS JIM GROSCH-
MANY OF YOU KNOW ME AS A-
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF CLIENTS
BUT IN THIS INSTANCE I AM
CALLING IN- SUPPORT ON A
PERSONAL BASIS. BY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- PRICE WHO IS MY
BROTHER IN LAW. AND WHOM I HAVE
HAD MANY LONG CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE WORK THAT HE DOES. I
WANT TO TELL YOU WHAT A MAN OF
INTEGRITY HE IS. AND HOW WELL
SUITED HE IS FOR THIS POSITION
YOU WILL NOT FIND ANYBODY MORE
COMMITTED. TO HELPING THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE
DISABILITIES AS HE EXPLAINED-
HE HAS WORKED FOR THE STATE IN
SOME TO PASS. FOR MANY MANY
YEARS HE UNDERSTANDS THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM THE CHALLENGES
AND I BELIEVE IN THE TIME OF
COLD IT HE IS ABSOLUTELY THE
BEST PERSON FOR THE JOB I KNOW
HOW MUCH ESPECT HE HAS. FOR
THE DIRECTORS WELL I THINK YOU
HAVE A WONDERFUL TEAM THERE AND
I ASK THAT YOU APPROVED- YOU
CONFIRM HIS APPOINTMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER.
GROSS NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY NINE LINE
NIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI RANDY WITH
THE COUNTY THEY HAVE CONTRACTED
WITH THEIR CREATIONS HERE TO
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OUT
BACK AND YOU CAN DOWN IN AT THE
DIRECTOR AND DR WE RIGHT AS THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF A HOSPITAL-
DEPARTMENT THEY OFTEN OPENER
THEIR LEADERSHIP HAVE BEEN
COOPERATIVE. WORKING WITH
COUNTY POPPING CHALLENGES
RELATED AMOUNT DIVERSION
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
MISSION NOW YEAH FACT IT'LL
COMMITMENT. WE'VE SEEN UNDER
CORBYN NINETEEN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DEDICATED TO THE
CARE. OF INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE HOSPITAL THE TIME KICKING
WHILE DIFFICULT- PRECAUTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THE FIFTY. FIVE
PATIENT THE BACK APARTMENT THEY
HOPE IT'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH BOND
YET H. ON. METAL DIVERSION
BUILDING A VISION OF THE FUTURE.
MENTAL HEALTH CAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SEVEN EIGHT LINE SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE IS A-
MADAM CHAIR NAY. THIS IS FOR
LUND APPLY IN THE FIRE ON
BEHALF THE NOW LINE ON ILLNESS
CALIFORNIA. IT IS A PLAY TO
SUPPORT THE CONTENT. STEPHANIE
CONDEMNED AND AT DIRECTOR STATE
HOSPITAL. OUR INTERACTION WITH
THE DIRECTOR OF CENTRAL
STALLING PRODUCTIVE AND HELPFUL
AS YET THAT COMPASSION THE
KNOWLEDGE AND A COMMITMENT TO A
BILL TO OUR LIVING WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS. BUT DIRECTORS
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEPARTMENT
POSITIVELY IMPACT BOTH THE
EMPLOYEES AND JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY THE. PATIENT AT THE
HOSPITAL. AS A FATHER A CHILD
WHO'S READ OF A STATE. SINCE
THEN OVER TWO YEARS NOW. I THE
IMPORT OF STEADFAST LEADERSHIP
ESPECIALLY DURING THE CALL THE
PANDEMIC. I'M DIRECTOR CLINT
AND- LEADERSHIP AGAINST TO OUR
FAMILY AS WELL AS MANY MANY
OTHERS FOUNDATION WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONFIRM HER
APPOINTMENT AS WELL AS MR
PRICES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER NINETY NINE NINE NINE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
ERIC YOUNG AND THE PRESIDENT OF
OUR LOCAL TO SIXTEEN. WE JUST
OVER A THOUSAND PARKING UNIT
NINETEEN EMPLOYEES WITHIN THE
STATE OPERA THE- PLEASE STAND
AND HOLD BOARD OF. DIRECTORS
CLEAN AND- BACKGROUND TWITTER
THAT APOLOGIES BANNON SUPPORT
AFFECT ME AND BY THE PRICE.
WITH A PERMANENT POSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
NEXT WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE
NINETY FIVE LINE NINE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CORY CELLS ARE LOW ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION PLEASE TO CALL IN
IN SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR CLINTON
AND CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR PRICE
IN THEIR- NOMINATIONS TO THESE
POSITIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU AT A MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER. ONE OH
EIGHT TWO NINE ONE ZERO EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH MADAM PRESIDENT PRO
pIS KOBE PRESIDING WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS- WE
REPRESENT- OVER THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED STATE LICENSED AND
CERTIFIED- PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS IN THE STATE
HOSPITALS- AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR CLENDENIN
AND SHE GOT IT CORRECT AND-
PRICE- NOMINATION TO HIS AND
THE LARGEST BRICK LEVEL OF CARE.
PROVIDER THE DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITAL SAY TEXT PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN PROTECTING THE HEALTH
MENTAL STABILITY AND SAFETY OF
OUR PATIENTS AND STAFF. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE MUST ENSURE
THE PATIENTS AND STAFF SAFETY-
WAY AS WELL AS AS PROTECT-
EVERYBODY IN THE HOSPITAL- BY
PROVIDING GREAT TREATMENT AND
CARE. IT'S DIRECTOR CLINTON.
AND HAS. BOB HAD AN OPEN DOOR
FOR THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
PANDEMIC AND HAS AFFORDED US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ME ON A BI
WEEKLY BASIS TO LET HER KNOW AS
WELL AS THE REST OF HER STAFF
KNOW- WHAT BOOTS ON THE GROUND
STAFFER FEELING AND HOW THINGS
ARE WORKING OUT- AT THE AT THE-
AT FACILITY LEVEL THIS IS BEEN.
INVALUABLE FOR US AND WE CANNOT
RECOMMEND ENOUGH- DIRECTOR OF
GLENDALE AND CHIEF DEPUTY PRICE
WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON'T NEXT WITNESS.
IT IS A GENTLEMAN IF HE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MATTER MODERATOR WILL
BE BACK WITH YOU IN A MOMENT-
LET ME COME BACK INTO ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN OPPOSTION.
TO EITHER APPOINTEE ARE SEEING
NO ONE IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
LET ME TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE ARE HAVE
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO
MADAM MODERATOR LET ME COME
BACK TO YOU. AND A REMINDER TO
WITNESSES ARE THREE MINUTES PER
WITNESS AND I THINK THAT. LAST
A SET OF- WITNESSES TOOK ABOUT
FIVE AND A HALF MINUTES SO
MATAMATA WRITER LET ME COME
BACK TO YOU- TO QUEUE UP
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION. AS AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. JUST A MOMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE LINE EIGHT
TO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD THE
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY YES I WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO
STEPHANIE CLENDENIN AND TO
STERLING PRICE- FIRST OF ALL
WHEN PAMELA PREVIEW SORRY
NEED YOU TO GIVE ME YOUR NAME
SORRY YOUR NAE- AND I I'M
SORRY. GO RIGHT AHEAD. GO AHEAD
MY NAME IS JOE OAK OAKS. THANK
YOU GO AHEAD. OKAY WHAT A
FORMER DIRECTOR PAM ALLEN. WHEN
SHE SAID WHO WILL WIN MISS
CLINTON WAS PRESIDENT SHE HAD
ASSURED THE SAME THAT THE
PATIENTS HAVE AN OUTLET FOR
THEIR GRIEVANCES TO BE FULLY
VETTED AND WE POPPED. NOW THIS
IS PROOF OF THIS WAS SENT. TO
THE APPOINTMENT OFFICE INTO THE
STAFFERS ON THE COMMITTEE
UNFORTUNATELY THAT PATIENT
RIGHT THAT SHE WAS REFERRING TO
HAS BECOME A FAILURE. ONE OF
THE THINGS. IN REGARDS TO THAT
IS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IN JANUARY THERE WAS
AT DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
COALINGA THERE IS A FULL AND
THEY WERE VIOLATION THAT DEALT
WITH LIKE COMMUNICATIONS TWO
ATTORNEYS COMMUNICATIONS TWO
OTHER PEOPLE THROUGH THE PHONE
AND ALL. AND EVEN THOUGH IT'S
RECORDED- AT THAT TIME AND NOW
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BRANDON
PRICE HE HAD SHARED THAT AND
THE QUOTE IS HE SAID THAT WHEN
HE GETS A RESPONSE REGARDING
TOMORROW OF PATIENTS RIGHT. IT
WILL BE POSTED. UP UNTIL TODAY
THIS THERE WAS NOTHING POSTED
THERE WAS NOTHING PUT IN THE
PATIENT CHARGE THERE WAS NO
DOCUMENTATION THAT THAT DENIAL
OF RIGHTS EVER HAPPENED I FIND
IT VERY DISCONCERTING. THAT
MISS MISS CLINTON DIDN'T WOULD
LET IT GO ALL THIS TIME. AND
IGNORE THE FACT THAT THERE'S NO
DOCUMENTATION THAT'S MOVING
FORWARD WHEN PATIENTS RIGHT
WHEN THE PATIENTS THEIR RIGHTS
ARE BEING DENIED. ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS WE'VE TALKED QUITE
A BIT ABOUT DEALING WITH THE
COLD AT NINETEEN. AND
DISCONCERTING THING IS PATIENCE
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. HAVE
SPOKEN QUITE A BIT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
COALINGA AND UP DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS THEY STILL HAVE
NOT SET UP A HOTLINE WHERE
PATIENTS OR- BOARD MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. CAN REPORT
VIOLATIONS THAT DEAL WITH THE
STAFF WE CONTINUE ADDS CO IT
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARSENAL'S
CALLING IT TO HAVE STAFF
MEMBERS GOING FROM QUARANTINE
UNITS. THAT EVEN HAVE THE COLD
IN NINETEEN AND WORKING ON
OTHER UNITS WHICH CONTINUES
TODAY. WITHIN THE LAST THREE
DAYS THERE WAS A NEW UNIT THAT
JUST HAD TEN PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE IN THE LAST
THREE DAYS. THAT BECOMES A VERY
ALARMING ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S
WE WAS REPORTED EARLIER BUT
SEPTEMBER FROM A QUARANTINE
UNIT WAS VISITING THAT. I
BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW I'M NOT
SAYING THAT. THE STAFF IN THE
CLINTON OR STERLING PRICE WOULD
BE A BAD EXAMPLE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS NEEDS TO BE
FIXED AND INVESTIGATED BEFORE
WE MOVE FORWARD. BECAUSE I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE
SHOWN ENOUGH THAT THEY WANT TO
CORRECT THESE PROBLEMS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR OAKES. OF
MATAMATA RAIDER NEXT WITNESS.
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX
LINE FIVE SIX WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M BARBARA COOK
HOME MEDICAID EVERY PARTNER IN
WASHINGTON DC TESTIFYING TO
OPPOSE THE CONFIRMATION OF
STAFF IN THE CLINTON. WHY
ACTING DIRECTOR THERE HAS BEEN.
OKAY BASED ON MY INVESTIGATION
OF THIS ARTICLE I WROTE WASTE
MISMANAGEMENT AND CORRUPTION
THAT COOLEY AS I WROTE IN MY
ARTICLE TITLED MODERN DAY
BELONGED IN THE GOLDEN STATE
WHICH RAN IN THE WASHINGTON
SPECTATOR LAST JUNE I EMAILED
SEVERAL. ADDITIONAL OPTIONS THE
LINK. BOB BEFORE I TO THE
DETAILS DURING THAT ARTICLE I
WANTED TO SAY THAT I TURNED.
FROM STRONG. CREATION ABOUT THE
WAY COLD IT IS BEING HANDLED IN
COALINGA. AND IT'S CONTRARY TO
WHAT. LONDON HAS SHOWN BIG
ABOUT THE PRECAUTIONS HAVE BEEN
OFTEN TAKEN FOR EXAMPLE
TELEPHONE FIFTY YEARS
COLLECTIVELY ONE AFTER THE
OTHER OR NOT SENATE TIME AND
IT'S TRULY THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
SAID THAT STAFF HAVE BEEN GOING
FROM. A UNIT THAT HAD CALLED
THE PATIENT UP ELSEWHERE IN THE
HOSPITAL SOCIAL DISTANCING IS
NOT. THE ROLE. PATIENTS WERE A
MASK. NO LONGER GET TO A REAL
GUN ROOM BUT LINE ONE AFTER
OTHER. OKAY ENGINE AND OF WHAT
I WROTE AND THEY ARE I YEAR.
YOU CONTROL INCREASE ARE IN NO
CRITICS DUE TO OVER FOR EXAMPLE
A LITTLE PIECES IN THE L. A.
TIMES ABOUT TWO PSYCHOLOGISTS-
BILLS WERE ROUTINELY A
CONSULTANT OVER A. HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND WENT. HI A
MILLION A HALF THE ONLY THING
YEARS MRS MACRON AND STOP ALL
EDUCATION COURSE. ACT COOK NOT
THE OTHER THE ALTHOUGH AND- IS
MANDATE BY THE STATE I NEED TO
RETURN TO SOCIETY THESE
PATIENTS INSTEAD OF BEING
WAREHOUSE FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES. NEED EDUCATION SHE SAID
IT WAS SHOCKED TO SAVE MONEY
ALSO LONGER WATCH MEN HAVE
LANGUISHED FOR YEARS WITHOUT A
TRIAL AS WAS TRUE OF GEORGE
VASQUEZ WHO IS KEPT SEVENTEEN
YEARS. FINALLY RELEASED IT
CUSTOM MADE AND OR AT LEAST
ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED THAT HAVE
NEVER HAD A TRIAL TO DECIDE IF
THEY SHOULD BE ASSEMBLY.
COMMENDED MOHRENSCHILDT ABOUT
MEDICAL NAGLER. WHICH BE IN MY
NEXT. BUT I CAN SAY THAT IN THE
U. KERR OF THE ORIGINAL ARTICLE.
I HAVE BEEN THE BILL MANY AND
DENTAL THE FIRST DURING ONE
MANAGER SHOWED THAT LONG. MAYBE
I'LL THAT DATA IN THIS COMBAT
ALREADY DOLLARS MISS ONLY EIGHT
DOLLARS COMPOUND NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS AND TO NOT
A LOT OF RADIO. DOLLARS THREE
MINUTES. WHO HAD ONLY EIGHTEEN
PLEASE MUTE THE SPEAKER. YOUR
LET ME FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
WE'RE AT MIN AND THIRTY SECONDS
AND- AS IS CUSTOMARY PRACTICE
AT THIS COMMITTEE PEOPLE
TYPICALLY GIVE THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
WE EXTENDED THAT- DURING THIS
DISCUSSION BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTOOD THERE WERE PEOPLE
WHO WANTED TO- SPEAK FURTHER
SO- JUST TO CLARIFY FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. MADAME MODERATOR
CAN WE GO TO THE NEXT SPEAKER
PLEASE. THAT'LL BE MY NUMBER
ONE ZERO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONE OH FIVE. YES MY NAME IS
JEFF CAMPBELL I READ THE
YOUTUBE CHANNEL THE H. USE THE
WEBSITE USA TO BE USED DOT COM
AND D. S. H. AT THE START ORG.
I'M SURE THE VOICES NOT ONLY A
PATIENT WHO SEPARATE BUT STAFF
AND POLICE WHO READ. A THIS
CHAIR ALL TELLING ME THAT I
SHOULD GO TO THE F. B. I. THAT-
THAT. THE FORMER DIRECTOR WAS
COMMITTING CRIMES. AND THERE'S
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF EVIDENCE ON
THIS CHANNEL THAT STEPHANIE
CLENDENIN AND STARTING PRICE
SHOULD BE REMOVED WORK FOR
THEIR POSITIONS NOT CONFIRMED
TO LEAD THIS DEPARTMENT IN THE
FUTURE. STEPHANIE CLEGG DIDN'T
HAS HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE PAST SIX YEARS AND HAS
FAILED AFTER PROMISING CENTER
HOLLY J. MITCHELL. YOUR LAST
CONFIRMATION HEARING AUGUST
TWENTY SIX TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
HEARING WHICH SHE WOULD LEAD TO
A STATE. IN A SEPARATE
DIRECTIONS THAT WAS WHEN MY
LAWYER TESTIFIED THIRTY NINE
MINUTES INTO THAT HEARING ABOUT
MY BEING DRUGGED AND PLACED IN
ISOLATION WHERE STEPHANIE WAS
PUT THROUGH THE LAST
CONFIRMATION WITH PAMELA.
DRUGGING PATIENTS WITHOUT A
MENTAL ILLNESS WHICH EXPOSED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BURKE
SEXY GORGEOUS VIOLENCE IN THE
PRIVACY HOSPITALS BY DR WILLIAM
ME ON AMAZON DOT COM. PAGE TO
NINETY EIGHT WHICH MOST MEMBERS
IN THIS LEGISLATURE I'VE SPOKEN
TO ARE NOT AWARE OF. I HAVE
BEEN EMAILING AND CALLING ALL
OF THE STAFF MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
WEEKS AB ALLEY JIM SHELLEY REES
AUSTIN. BERRY FRUIT AND RUCHED
CRACKING AND MANY OTHERS WITH
SPECIFIC EVIDENCE AND
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THESE TWO
CANDIDATES INCLUDING THE
RECENTLY BE SEPARATE.
VOICEMAILS THIS CALL. ABOUT THE
GREAT PATIENTS ARE CURRENTLY IN
WITH A DSA. WE WILL BE POSTING
THESE VOICEMAILS LEFT ON YOUR
OFFICES ON YOUTUBE PROBABLY
TOMORROW. AS OF THIS MORNING
STAFF STILL ARE DEFIANTLY
REFUSING TO WEAR MASKS AND
APPROPRIATELY CLEAN LIVING UNIT
AS KOBE NINETEEN TECH SUPPORT
HOLD IN VERY SPEEDY. FACILITIES
THE P. R. D. R. C. LEGAL
DEPARTMENT CALLED ME LAST NIGHT
TO SAY THEY ARE PROBABLY THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACTION ABOUT
GOLDEN NINETEEN CAN. CONDITIONS
AT. I BROKE THE STORY WEEKS
AGO. ON MY YOU TO GET ALL THAT
INFO BECAUSE- WERE BEING
BECAUSE- IN SODA. AND PATENT.
TO WORK AS SWEAT. TO SORT DIRTY
LAW FIRST. THOSE IT'LL BE ON MY
YOU TUBE. SURELY INSTEAD. HAD
THAT. TO FOR DEFY STAFF TO WEAR
MASS. CLEARLY BE LIVING. AT
CùNG PATENT OR TO GO WHICH IS
SIX AGAIN I TO YOU TO PAY.
TODAY THEY HAVE ALLOWED A LOT
USE OF STAY COMPUTER. WHICH HAS
RESULT IN. BEING B. AND DID I
SHOULD. YOU KNOW THE- COUPLE OF
TWO PEOPLE MEMBERS. ETCETERA.
DR TALKING TO MEMBERS OF THE
STAFF I HAVE DONE THAT I HAVE
LONG. WITH THREE AUSTIN YOUR
PRESS SECRETARY MR I TO
CREATION I GOT TO GET BUDGET IS
THIS MORNING GAMBLE BUT EVEN. A
THREE YEAR ALL KNEW THE I WAS
GOING TO SPEAK FOR A MEMBER OF
FIVE BEEN TODAY. AND I'M
TELLING I'M SO I DID NOT HAVE
THAT IN. MISTER **** THANK YOU
FOR YOU. TEST OUR- MATTER
MODERATOR NECKS WITNESS. EVEN
CHEN IF YOU WISH SPEAK IN A-
YOU MAY PRESS THEN ZERO. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE SO PLEASE CONTINUE.
MADAME MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE WE
WILL BE BACK OUR UNDER THE NEXT
APPOINTMENT- LET ME BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE
ARE FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SENATOR ROTH. WELL
LET ME JUST SAY THIS MAN
APPROACHED HIM AND TO THE FOLKS
WHO WERE STILL ON THE LINE YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A PROCESS HERE AND
WE HAVE A COMMITTEE STAFF IT'S
JUST ASSIGNED TO US FROM RULES.
FRANKLY THIS IS THE FIRST I'VE
pTHAN ANY OF MY- CAPITOL OFFICE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF. WERE
CONTACTED ABOUT A RULES
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS SO I
WILL. HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
THEM ABOUT THAT. BUT IT'S HARD
TO DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH THESE
ISSUES WHEN THEY'RE NOT
PRESENTED TO US. IN WRITING SO
THAT WE CAN REVIEW THEM AND
CONSULT WITH THE APPROPRIATE
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE MAKING THE COMPLAINTS AND
ASK APPROPRIATE QUESTIONS OF
THOSE THAT ARE PRESENTED FOR. A
CONFIRMATION I WILL ALSO SAY
THIS BECAUSE I'VE HEARD ARE PRO
TEM MAKE THESE COMMENTS BEFORE
WE HAVE A PROCESS IN THIS
COMMITTEE THAT I'M SURE SHE
WILL REITERATE. WHEREBY WE
FOLLOW UP WITH ISSUES THAT ARE
RAISED DURING THE CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS AND I FOR ONE INTEND
TO FOLLOW UP WITH THESE ISSUES-
WITH THE NOMINEES. WHO I ASSUME
WILL. TAKE NOTES AS THEY HAVE
BEEN I'M SURE AND WILL FOLLOW
UP AND WILL TRY TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE APPROPRIATE AND- AND NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED. AS A
LEGISLATURE WE ALSO HAVE MEANS
OF ADDRESSING ISSUES WHETHER
IT'S THE STATE AUDITOR OR OUR
OWN OVERSIGHT SO. I WITH THAT
MAN APPROACH THEM I DO INTEND
TO MAKE. DOMINIS I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE AND EXPECT THAT
SHE WILL.FOLLOW UP WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE TODAY
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
ARE VALID ISSUES THAT YOU WILL
ADDRESS THEM. IN THE
APPROPRIATE FASHION AND-
PROVIDE US MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
WITH AN UPDATE. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM I MOVE THE CUTS.
THANK YOU US SENATOR ROTH
SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU
AMANDA PRO TEM. I WAS NOT AWARE
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
FIRST TWO WITNESSES. MY OFFICE
WAS CONTACTED BY MISTER
GAMEBOARD. AWARE OF HIS
CONCERNS THAT. AT NO POINT IN
THE COMMUNICATIONS WITH MY
OFFICE WAS THERE. ANY
COMMITMENT AS TO DURATION OF
TESTIMONY THE PRO TEM HAS MADE
IT CLEAR THAT SHE AFFORDED.
MORE TIME THAN USUALLY.
ALLOCATED IN WAS DONE IN A-
FAIR MANNER PROVIDING. ALL
THREE IN OPPOSITION WITH THREE
MINUTES EACH. YOU'RE ALSO ALL
ABLE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN.
COMMENTS OR TESTIMONY WITH NO
LIMITATION ON ISSUES YOU MIGHT
WISH TO COVER OR SHARE WITH US
AND THAT COULD STILL BE DONE
AFTER TODAY'S HEARING- I WOULD
LIKE THROUGH THE CHAIR TO SEE
IF EITHER OF THE APPOINTEES
WOULD WISH TO COMMENT IF NOT
SPECIFICALLY ON SPECIFIC ISSUES
RAISED- GENERALLY ON THE NATURE
OF SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
SEEM TO FOCUS ON COALINGA. SO
THROUGH THE CHAIR I WOULD
APPRECIATE GIVING THE NOMINEES
THAT OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU ARE
THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING LET
ME START WITH- DIRECTOR-
CLENDENIN AND ASK IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO MISTER PRICE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADD A
COMMENT- SO. MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE RAISED TODAY HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION.
RECEIVE INFORMATION ON BOTH
ENDS THROUGH EMAILS- FROM OUR
PATIENTS THROUGH VOICE MAILS
FROM OUR PATIENTS. AND AS
THROUGH- MAKING RAISE CONCERNS
TO THE OFFICE- ON PATIENTS
RIGHTS AND THEY DO AND THEY
ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADD TO
RAISE CONCERNS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH I WE AS A DEPARTMENT
SHAILA MANY. HEALTH CARE AND-
AS SERVING INDIVIDUALS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS HAVE A
NUMBER OF OVERSIGHT ENTITIES
THAT I'M CONSISTENTLY AND
FREQUENTLY I REVIEW THE
COMPLAINTS THAT. ARE PRESENTED-
WE HAVE AND I DID TOO. BUT ONES
THAT COME INTO DEPARTMENT AS
THOSE ISSUES WHETHER THEY COME
INTO MYSELF OR THEY COME INTO
THAT AND SHE DIFFERENT PRICE OR
ANY OF OUR LEADERS. OR STOP.
MEMBERS ARE REVIEWED AND THEY
ARE HADN'T PROVIDED TO BE OUR
CHIEF OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
OUR OFFICE AND PROTECTIVE
SERVICES IN OUR AND- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTORS. AND OUR- ADMITTEDLY
SERVICES AS SO IF THEY ARE AND
IF THEY ARE ISSUES- THAT ARE
UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
SUPPORT IN THEIR REPORTAGE THE
OFFICE OF ONE FOR SENATE
SUPPORT WHICH IS THE OVERSIGHT
ENTITY THAT WAS ESTABLISHED. AS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AS WELL AS
THEIR AND ALWAYS ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS- INTO THE ISSUES
ARE AND WHERE WE DO HAVE AND
FIND ISSUES WE DO ADDRESS THEM
I AM EITHER A THROUGH
PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION. AS WE HAVE TERM TERMS
INDIVIDUALS AS A RESULT- ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE FOUND AS A MATTER
OF ISSUES OF RACE AND I CAN
ALSO SAY THAT WORK VERY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
OFFICERS A FEW SHIPWRIGHTS WHO
DOES INVESTIGATE THE ISSUES AND
THE CONCERNS THAT ARE RAISED
FIND BE- BY THE PATIENTS AND-
ALSO MYSELF AND DIRECTLY HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE DIRECTOR
OVER A SYSTEMIC CONCERNS. THAT
IF THE IDENTIFIES TO SYSTEMIC
CONCERNS OR IF A PARTICULAR
CONCERN- IS SUCH THAT THEY FELT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION SO I AND THEN WE
WORKS IT'S ALL ABOUT NOT THAT
CONCERNED SO THERE'S A NUMBER
OF WAYS IN WHICH AND ISSUES ARE
BROUGHT OR- AND CONSISTENTLY-
REVIEW ADDRESSED INVESTIGATED.
AND IN RESPONSE TO THANK YOU A
CHIEF DEPUTY PRICE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS SHE WOULD ADD TO THAT.
ACTUALLY NO I THINK THAT
DIRECTOR CLINTON'S- EXPLANATION
WAS A PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE
THANK YOU AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE AND RESPECT THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE IN PLACE- TO
PROTECT PATIENT RIGHTS. I WOULD
SAY WITHOUT HAVING EVIDENCE TO
CONFIRM. THE VERACITY OF
CONCERNS. I THINK IT WOULD BE A-
IN MY OF WHAT WE HEARD. TO MAKE
SURE. THAT FOR SIR SENATOR
AFTER USE THAT STAFF ARE
REQUIRED TO WEAR MASKS AT ALL
TIMES IN THE WORKPLACE. IN THAT
THERE BE A LOOK TOWARDS STAFF
MOVING FROM AREAS OF COVERT
NINETEEN PATIENTS TO AREAS OF
NON COVERT NINETEEN PATIENTS
AGAIN I DON'T HAVE EVIDENCE IN
FRONT OF ME. THAT JUST UPON
HEARING THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
WERE SEEM AN EASY ARM OVERSIGHT
RECOMMENDATION TO DOUBLE CHECK
WITH LEADERSHIP ON AT COHEN. IN
AT ALL STATE HOSPITALS AS ZERO
TOLERANCE FOR STAFF NOW MASKS
IN TO DOUBLE TRIPLE THE
DECONTAMINATION EFFORTS AND
AGAIN NOT PASSING JUDGMENT ON
EITHER OF YOU BUT JUST THE FACT
THAT THIS IS BEEN BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION IT SEEMS LIKE
WOULD WARRANT. IMMEDIATE
LOOKING INTO AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO DO THAT AND
WITH THAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER REMINDING LET
ME JUST R. UNDERSCORE I HIS
COMMENTS RELATED TO CERTAINLY.
THE PRECAUTIONS AROUND COVE IT
AND DIRECTOR AND- IT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CAN I GET YOUR
COMMITMENT THAT YOU WILL-
FOLLOW UP ON THAT AND I WILL
ENSURE THAT MY STAFF AS WE HAVE
DONE A NUMBER OF TIMES FOLLOWS
UP ON THOSE ISSUES OUT
RECOGNIZING THAT ON SOME OF THE
OTHER ISSUES. YOU HAVE-
APPROPRIATE VENUES FOR PEOPLE
TO MAKE THOSE COMPLAINTS AND-
IF I CAN GET YOUR- AGREEMENT
THAT YOU WILL FOLLOW UP ON A
PARTICULARLY ON SENATOR
MINING'S COMMENTS I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. S. ZERO THANK
YOU BOTH VERY MUCH- CENTER ROSS
I THINK I. WILL SO MOVED. AND
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BATES MONNING AYE MONNING
AYE ROTH AYE ROTH AYE BOOK AYE
AYE ATKINS HI INSIDE. IT IS
FOUR ZERO WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR SENATOR BATES AND- LET
ME GO AHEAD AND CONGRATULATE
YOU BOTH AND WITH APPRECIATION
FOR THE JOB THAT YOU HAVE DONE
AS PUBLIC SERVICE AND ALSO WITH
FOR THE JOB THAT YOU STILL.
WILL NEED TO DO AND THANK YOU
AND CONGRATULATIONS. EUROPE I
THANK YOU OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO THE LAST
APPOINTMENT REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND THAT WOULD BE DR FIVE
ALEXANDER SHERIFF'S MEMBER OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY UNIFIED
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
BOARD. LET ME WELCOME YOU AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE DR- WHAT WE
WILL DO I WILL GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY AS- THE OTHERS TO.
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS I
RECOGNIZE ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT- IN
PARTICULAR THAT IS SUPPORTING
YOU OR WHO HAS SUPPORTED YOU.
AND THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS WITHOUT
LET ME JUST SAY WELCOME DOCTOR
SHERIFF'S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THIS YOUR FIRM PATIENTS. AND
CONSIDERATION OF MY RE
APPOINTMENT TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BOARD- I'M I'M NOT
GONNA INTRODUCE ANY FAMILY I DO
HAVE MY SERVICE DOG WITH A
SMALL **** UNDER THE TABLE. WHO
IS PROVIDING SUPPORT TO ME FOR
I APPRECIATE THE TODAY I AM
LIVED IN THE GREATER CENTRAL
VALLEY SINCE STARTING MEDICAL
SCHOOL. AT UC DAVIS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR I COMPLETED MY
FAMILY MEDICINE RESIDENCY AT
UCSF FRESNO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE. AFTER WHICH MY FAMILY
PHYSICIAN WIFE AND I
VOLUNTEERED FOR TWO YEARS WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE. WHEN
WE RETURN TO CALIFORNIA WE
WANTED TO MAKE A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITY
WHERE WE COULD OFFER CHAIRED TO
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY REGARDLESS
OF PAY STATUS. AND BEGAN OUR
PRIVATE PRACTICE IN FLOUR THEN
ACCOUNT IN. TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE SOUTH OF FRESNO.
OVER TIME THE ROLE OF AIR
QUALITY. AS A COMMUNITY
DETERMINATIVE HEALTH BECAME
MORE AND MORE OBVIOUS OUR
YOUNGEST DAUGHTER SALESMAN.
EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH RATES OF
CHILDHOOD ASTHMA IN OUR
PRACTICE IN THE ENTIRE VALLEY.
AND A GROWING COHORT OF OLDER
PATIENTS DEVELOPING LUNG
DISEASE WHO LACKED ANY RISK
FACTORS BUT FOR A LIFE IN ONE
OF THE WORST AR QUALITY BASINS
IN THE UNITED STATES. WE HAVE
MADE SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
PROGRESS IN OUR DAILY THAT
PROGRESS HAS BEEN DRIVEN BY
HEALTH PROMOTING STRICTER AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS THAT PROGRESS
COULD ONLY HAPPEN BECAUSE OF
THE ENGAGEMENT OF PUBLICATIONS
SHE IS BUSINESSES. COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES RESEARCHERS AND THE
INDIVIDUAL CHOICES OF VALLEY
RESIDENTS. MY PRIMARY RESPONSE
IN THIS APPOINTMENT IS AS A
DOCTOR TO PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH.
SOLUTIONS ARE CLEARLY COMPLEX
AND I HAVE BEEN WILL BE SERVED
BY MY SMALL BUSINESS MEDICAL
PRACTICE AND BEING ENGAGED IN
GETTING FORTY ACRES OF RAISINS
TO MARKET EVERY YEAR FOR THE
PAST TWO DECADES I DO KNOW
FIRST HAND THE EFFECTS OF
REGULATIONS. AND THE CHALLENGES
OF BALANCING I. IN CRACKED THE-
IN MAKING A BUSINESS THROUGH
FOR CLIENTS STAND FOR PLAYERS
THE COMMUNITY AND THE OWNER. I
AM GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
I HAVE HAD TO ADVOCATE FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH DURING MY PAST
TERMS ON THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
BOARD AND I HOPE THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE SENATE AS A WHOLE WILL
ACT FAVORABLY SO THAT I CAN
CONTINUE ANOTHER FOUR YEARS IN
THIS IMPORTANT PUBLIC SERVICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET ME TURN TO YOU SENATOR
MONNING. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND- DR SHARE IF I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE I'VE
HAD THE HONOR OF GETTING TO
KNOW YOU IN MY CAPACITY SERVING
ON THE- CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WITH YOU- I
THINK YOUR- ABILITY TO BE A
VOICE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AMBRIDGE. FROM AMONG AND
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. IS A TESTAMENT TO YOUR
ONGOING CONTRIBUTIONS BOTH AT
THE POLLUTION CONTROL BOARD AND
ON. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. I KNOW YOU
SERVE BOTH AS A PHYSICIAN BUT
ALSO AS A GROWER IN SO YOU YOU
BRIDGE- SOME OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN YOUR OWN WORK IN
YOUR OWN LIFE MADAM PRO TEM I
HAVE NO SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AT
THIS TIME I JUST WANT TO THANK
DR SURE FOR HIS. CONTINUED
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIANS SPECIFICALLY THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU- I DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ARE NOT SURE IF I
JUST WANT TO OUR LOCAL OF THE
CAR OF MY CALL OFTEN MONEY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
YOU'D BE ENOUGH ARE KIND OF
SEVEN UP FOR QUITE AWHILE SO-
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE-
RENOMINATION AND- WE'LL SEE YOU
ON THE FLOOR. THAT THANK YOU
AGAIN. IF YOU'RE THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN TH. THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS EITHER BUT I WILL
SHARE- LAST FALL I WAS INVITED
TO SPEAK AT A CONFERENCE IN
FRESNO. AND SINCE I WAS DRIVING
UP THERE DECIDED TO SPEND A
COUPLE DAYS VISITING OTHER
ENTITIES THAT DO BUSINESS
BEFORE THE STATE. AND I WILL
TELL YOU MY LUNGS BURNED THE
ENTIRE TIME IN MY EYES WATER
THE ENTIRE TIME THAT I WAS IN
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. IT
REALLY REALLY TROUBLED ME SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP PRESSING
FORWARD NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO
LIVE IN THAT KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT PARTICULARLY YOU
KNOW IN CALIFORNIA SO KUDOS TO
YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND CONTINUE
THE EFFORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN SENATOR
ROTH. THANK ABOUT AND
ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTIONS DR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE. OF
THE ENVIRONMENT- AND THE HEALTH
OF OUR CITIZENS AND RESIDENTS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO.
AGAIN. CONGRATULATIONS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOUR
UC FROM A- THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU CAN YOU CAN I YES
MAKE ONE COMENT YES AND I
CAN'T. I HATE TO SINGLE OUT ANY
ONE OF YOU BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK. SENATOR ROSS FOR HIS
WORK ON THE BUDGET AND SUPPORT.
FOR SONG BROWN FUNDING. OF MY
WIFE AND I- SHARED A SONG BROWN
FELLOWSHIP EARLIER IN OUR
MEDICAL CAREERS HERE AND WE USE
THAT TO PARTNER WITH UCSF. TO
DEVELOP A GERIATRICS
CURRICULUM. AND THE TEACHING
NURSING HOME. AND WE'RE PROUD
THAT THAT PROCESS CONTINUES
TODAY AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
TRAIN LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND PHYSICIANS
IN TRAINING- A QUIPPING THEM TO
HELP CARE FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE ELDERS AND SHOW. A
SONG BROWN HAS BEEN IMPORTANT.
IN IN OUR LIVES AND- IT IT'S
GIVE TO US CONTINUES TO GIVE
TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SONG BROWN IN THE
PAST WELL I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
WILL KEEP FIGHTING FOR THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
SO MUCH DR THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH ARE. CLEARLY YOU'RE A
PUBLIC SERVANT IN MULTIPLE WAYS
AND WE THANK YOU FOR THAT- I'M
GONNA. GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
ALL STARRED IN HIS ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE WHERE WE ARE. IF
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE HERE TO SUPPORT. OUR
DOCTOR SHERIFF'S. OKAY I SEE NO
ONE STEPPING FORWARD IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE LET ME
TAKE A LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NO ONE THERE
MADAME MODERATOR I'M COMING
BACK TO YOU TO SEE IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC VIA
TELECONFERENCE IT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF DR
SHERIFF'S. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
AT THE SHIP JAMES IT'S NOW
MISTER MODERATOR GOING FORWARD
I WANT. THANK YOU FOR MAKING
SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
DISTINCTION I APPRECIATE THAT
AND- WE ARE PREPARED FOR YOUR
WITNESSES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK OUT IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEM IS ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE DO HAVE A COUPLE THAT
ARE QUEUING UP THE FLOORS OF
THE PROVIDE LIGHT NUMBERS AND
THEN GET THEM IN THE QUEUE FOR
US WONDERFUL. WE WILL START
WITH LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN THAT'S TRIPLE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS LOUIS BROWN A CALLING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF ROGER ISOM CEO AND
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COTTON GENERATION GROWERS
ASSOCIATION. WESTERN AND
CROSSCOUNTRY SUBSTATION. WE'RE
PROUD TO LEND OUR SUPPORT FOR
DR SHERIFF'S REAPPOINTMENT CAL.
REACH BOARD. WE APPRECIATE HIS
BALANCE AND HIS ABILITY TO
SUPPORT INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THAT
HAVE. DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB AND
IN ADVANCING THE GOALS FOR
CLEAN AIR WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH HIM FOR ANOTHER
FOUR YEARS THANK YOU AND PLEASE
VOTE AYE. THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN WITNESS. NEXT WITNESS OF
THE LINE NUMBER NINETY EIGHT
THAT'S NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. Y.
NINETY EIGHT IF YOU CAN CHECK
FOR SELF MEET WE ARE HEARING
AUDIO TIME. THAT WAS MY I DON'T
ALL. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
APPROACH IN THIS IS TO.
ABERNATHY WITH THE PRODUCED
COUNCIL. HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
BELIEVE THAT YOU ALSO HAVE
WRITTEN COPY OF SUPPORT ON YOUR
DOCKET FOR FUTURE REFERENCE I
NEED BE. WHAT I WANT TO SIMPLY
START BY SAYING THAT I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF BOTH
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONAL
GETTING TO KNOW AND WORK WITH
DOCTOR SHARES FOR SEVERAL YEARS
NOW. AND HAVE ALWAYS BEEN VERY
APPRECIATIVE. OF HIS OPENNESS
TO LEARNING AND UNDERSTANDING
ALL SIDES OF ISSUES THAT MAY
ARISE IN THE BURKE COMPLEX
ARENA- POLLUTION AND REGULATORY
SCHEMES. WHAT DID I DO I HAVE%
TO COME IN THE COMPUTER SAID
HIS APPROACH IS ALWAYS BEEN
VERY BALANCED. TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WHICH IS THE PRIMARY ROLE OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PCD
PHARMA THE ENVIRONMENT AND AS
DR SURE MENTIONED AS A FARMER
ALSO THE ECONOMY. SO IT IS WITH
THAT AND MY PERSONAL BONUS OF
DOCTORS THAT- WE WOULD WE WOULD
GREATLY SUPPORT DATA BOTH FOR
HIS REAPPOINTMENT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WITHIN WILL COME
FROM LINE NUMBER EIGHTY THAT
EIGHT PER GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
A- GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. AND I'M SURE I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME TO
SPEAK OUT FOR OF. MY GOOD
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE SANDY
SHARES. BUT HE'S KNOWN TO HIS
FRIENDS- I'VE KNOWN AND WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE DOCTOR SHARES
AS I AM THE- CEO OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA HAS MCGUIRE. AND
PRIOR TO THAT WORK UCSF
RESIDENT THE- OUT WEST I STAND
HERE AND- HIS COMMITMENT TO HIS
PATIENTS IN HIS COMMUNITY. THAT
IS WITHOUT WITHOUT A DOUBT-
SOME OF THE HIGHEST I'VE EVER
SEEN- HE SPENDS HIS TIME- THOSE
FARMING. GREAT AND- WORKING
WITH HIS WIFE IS ALSO A
POSITION. BEING PATIENT IN THE
CITY OF POWER- PART TIME AND
STILL TEACHING RESIDENTS EVERY
WEEK AND SOMEHOW MANAGES TO
FULFILL HIS COMMITMENTS BOTH.
THE AIR DISTRICT BOARD LOCALLY
AND TO THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. I HAPPEN TO
KNOW THAT HE NEEDS REGULARLY
WITH THE VARIOUS- RESIDENT OF
THE GROUP IN THERE- THAT BALLY
IN THEIR ORGANIZATIONS-
ALTHOUGH YOU POINT. IN ORDER TO
BE PREPARED FOR THOSE MEETINGS
AND BE SURE THAT NEWSLETTER.
ALL THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
THE PROBLEM AND THE IMPACT OF
ANY DECISIONS THAT BOARD MIGHT
PAY. ARE SO HE CAN DO SO WITH
GOOD CONSCIOUS BUT ALWAYS
LOOKING THROUGH. THE I HAVE L.
DOCTORS. IS AN OUT IMAGE FIRST
AS THIS IS WHY. ARE WHEN
THEY'RE NOT DOING THERE ARE
BALLING. TO WORK WITH PEOPLE IN
OTHER PARTS OF WORLD OR IN
OTHER PARTS OUR ABOUT I CAN
NEVER STOP ENOUGH JUST HOW
CRITICAL DOCTORS. WHICH IS IN
THIS CAR. AND WE'RE REALLY. FOR
YOUR CONTINUED APPOINTMENT AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO A SOLID-
UNANIMOUS VOTE. FOR DR SHERIFF
TODAY THANK YOU BEFORE YOU HANG.
UP CAN YOU GIVE ME YOUR NAME.
OKAY I DIDN'T WANT TO INTRODUCE
THE SPEAKER AND I'M SO SORRY I
DIDN'T- A REMINDER TO WITNESSES.
TO PLEASE THAT WAS KEVIN
HAMILTON THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT I MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. YES
APOLOGY THAT WAS ONLY RELIGIOUS
TREE FELL AS PERSONALLY DID
DISCONNECT UPON- ENDING THEIR
SPEECH I WILL GO TO THE NEXT
LINE WHICH IS LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE. ONE ONE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU. HI
YEAH HI MY NAME IS. DON EIGHTY
THREE A. D. D. AND I'M A
POSITION ACTUALLY HERE IN
FRESNO AND ALSO PRESIDENT ELECT
OF THE PRESENT BUT THEY'RE A
MEDICAL- SOCIETY AND- I'VE
KNOWN DOCTOR SHARES FOR. OVER
FORTY YEARS- BOTH PERSONALLY
AND ALSO THROUGH THE MEDICAL
SOCIETY HE WAS- IS THE PAST
PRESIDENTOF OUR MEDICAL
SOCIETY AND HEREBY I'VE WORKED.
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS OF
REGARDING AIR QUALITY IN THE
VALLEY WE HELP PUT OUT A
BROCHURE ENOUGH YEARS AGO ABOUT
WHAT THE DOCTOR WANTS YOU DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THEIR POLLUTION. AND
HE RECEIVED OUR MEDICAL SIDE IS
SPECIAL PROJECTS SERVICE AWARD
FOR HIS WORK ARE PROMOTING YOUR
QUALITY IN OUR VALLEY- AND THIS
ALSO FALLS INVOLVED
COLLABORATING WITH OTHER
MEDICAL SOCIETIES INTERVALLIC
HE'S PERFORMED. ABLY AS A
MEMBER OF THE- BELAIR DISTRICT
AND THEIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
COMMUNICATED WITH US PHYSICIANS
IN OUR MEDICAL SOCIETY ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE BUT WE
NEED TO DO. TO PUSH FOR A FOR
BETTER AIR QUALITY. AND SO I
HIGHLY RECOMMEND HIM FOR HIS RE
APPOINTMENT TO THIS POSITION
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE
ARE NO MORE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU IN A MOMENT. LET'S COME
BACK INTO ROOM. THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND TAKE WITNESSES
THAT MAY HERE OFFICE. TO THE
APPOINTMENT. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO ONE
STEPPING FORWARD IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE LET ME TAKE A
LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
OBVIOUSLY NO ONE IS IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION SO MISTER MODERATOR
I'M COMING BACK TO YOU AND
TELECONFERENCE FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO MAY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME YOUR
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE THAT'S
ONE. ZERO AND THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
TODAY FOR US MR MODERATOR. OKAY
COMING BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES I
WILL LOOK TO SENATOR MONICA DID
YOU WISH TO MAKE THE MOTION YES
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR I AM
HONORED TO MAKE THEM MOTION. IN
SUPPORT OF DR SHERIFF'S AND I
ALSO WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
BEAUTIFUL BACKDROP I THINK THAT
LOOKS LIKE HALF DOME. I THINK
YOUR GOAL IS TO BRING THE AIR
QUALITY FROM HALF DOME INTO
THE- VALLEY FLOOR SO GOOD LUCK
IN YOUR CONTINUED AFTER YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WE ARE I'M GOING
TO ABSTAINED JUST FOR TODAY
BECAUSE I HAD A FEW ENQUIRIES
AND DUE TO MY ABSENCE- YEAH THE
ONLY IF I WAS NOT ABLE TO
FOLLOW UP THAT TOUGH. JUST FOR
TODAY SO I'VE SEEN. IT'S
RUNNING I MONNING AYE. ROTH
ROTH AYE WILK ALL RIGHT WILK
AYE. ATKINS HI ATKINS HI FOUR
ZERO THAT IS FOR- IN SUPPORT
ONE ABSTENTION YOUR
CONFIRMATION IS APPROVED THANK
YOU ARE CONFIRMED THANK YOU SO
MUCH DR SHERIFF'S. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BYE BYE OKAY- OUR
FINAL ITEM FOR TODAY'S AGENDA
IS THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND. I
BELIEVE I'M PULLING UP I NUMBER
IN OUT. LET ME JUST DOUBLE
CHECK AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE I NEED TO
SEPARATE OUT OKAY MISS BATES.
ALL RIGHT OKAY SO. FOR AND LET
ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
UNDERSTOOD LET ME LET ME JUST
FIVE MILLION- OLD PART OKAY AND
CAN I TAKE ITEM TO IN AND ARE
ONE ITEM YEAH I DON'T. YEAH
OKAY- OKAY THAT'S FINE. NO NO
NO THAT'S FINE SO- WE WOULD
TAKE. TO AYE SEPARATELY. ARE
YOU OKAY MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
THAT AND THEN- ARE IN
SEPARATELY. AND THEN I WOULD
REALLY ISSUES AND OKAY THAT
MAKES IT EASIER FOR YOU I IT
DOES I UNDERSTAND OKAY THEN I
WILL INTERTAPE HOW BOUT WE DO
THIS I'M GOING TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. ON ITEM TWO AND CAN I
HAVE A MOTION MOVED THANK YOU
SENATE ROTH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES
BATES NOT VOTING MONNING NIGHT
ON AYE ROTH ROTH AYE WILK NOT
VOTING WILL COULD NOT VOTING
ATKINS HI TECH INSIDE AND ZERO
THAT IS THREE VOTES IN SUPPORT
OF TWO OF STANCHIONS- IT- IS
CONFIRMED OKAY LET ME TAKE OUR
ITEMS TO I. O. N. R. MAY I HAVE
A MOTION. WE'RE THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH MADAM SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL. NOT VOTING IT'S
NOT VOTING MONNING THANK
MONNING AYE ROTH FIVE ROTH AYE
WILK HI WILK AYE ATKINS HI
ATKINS FIVE FORTY ZERO THANK
YOU SO ITEMS OPTED TO AYE- AN
ARC IT IS FOR IN SUPPORT ONE OF
STANCHION IT PASSES. SO NOW I
WILL TAKE A MOTION ON ITEM TWO
F. G. H. J. K. L. M. P. Q. SO
MOVE THANK YOU SENATOR MODDING
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. EIGHTH ALL RIGHT THE
FIVE MINING. AYE MONNING AYE
ROTH FIVE. I WILK HI I ATKINS
FIVE I CONCISE FIVE TWO ZERO
AND THAT IS UNANIMOUS FOR THAT
LIST THANK YOU I NOW I. WANT
TO- OPEN THEROLE OF FOUR ITEMS.
LET'S LET'S DO IT THIS WAY OPEN
THE ROLE ON ITEM ONE A. M. ONE
A. O. I'M SORRY WE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON ONE EIGHT- AND THAT IS
THAT COULD REMAIN. CLOSED RIGHT
OKAY I THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY FOR KEEPING ME ON
TRACK LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON
ITEM ONE B. BATES FIVE BATES I
FIVE TWO ZERO. THAT IS
CONFIRMED FIVE TWO ZERO. OP
LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM ONE
C. N. D. HE WON CMT BATES ALL
RIGHT BATES I. FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE TWO ZERO- THOSE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED AND
I THINK THAT IS THE EXTENT OF
OUR AGENDA YES WITH THAT WE ARE
THE RULES COMMITTEE OF- AUGUST
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.